c'est en train de partir alors
aujourd'hui j'ai carrément 0 caméra
nancy ça arrive
alors ça lance le temps de
arrivé de retrouver tout le monde le
live est déjà lancée mais
avec la bascule il faut qu'on récupère
du monde
allez je pense que c'est parti on à
l'échiquier
et on n'a qu'à fuir ou déjà
alors ça doit pas être la partie annoncé
ils ont ils ont bougé les pièces
n'importe comment il ya quelqu'un qui a
foutu le bordel
et donc l'échiquier c'est censé être le
2 mai on va se mettre en grande cas mais
bon voilà regard regarde comme on est
bien malade c'est la première journée au
final mort où on arrive
il a pris un starbucks hikaru le douceur
regarde c'est un starbucks est sûre je
crois je vous connais de logo vert
il est venu juste en espagne pour boire
du café dégueulasse non mais c'est
magnifique en fait si la ville a fait
3000 km pour boire de la merde le frérot
c'est quand même pas de bol eu bon
désolé 1 c'est une blague évidemment
rien contre starbucks spécifiquement
mais bon c'est une petite blague sur
hikaru
ce placement de produit ah non il s'est
fait dégager son et il se l'est fait
dégager je crois qui lui ai expliqué que
c'était un sponsor arbitres
ouais parce que tu sais que t'as pas le
droit d'avoir bien sûr à la fidh au banc
à mende blad à moissac a
commencé sa partie a pu voir sa mère
d'habitués le
hauban petite amende à mon avis j'espère
que la fidh value on voit une petite
facture de 50000 euros pour le placement
de produit
alors pas très beau le poids de
starbucks
ça commence bien pour nom ça commence
très bien
alireza il a l'air en pleine confiance
un
regard il fait un petit sourire car au
regard il fait ils envoient des petits
sourires y est très heureux
regarde
bien tout comment ça s'écrit moi ce con
tu commences les
quand tu commentes l'écrémage de michao
parti kwa
l'a envoyé crêpes 4,5 grimal déjà ça
fait ça fait une mite de jeu il n'y a
même pas eu de jeu il ya déjà 4 5
grimace qui sont partis assez
extraordinaire et un petit et quattro
monsieur bien sûr de quattro
bien sûr de quattro parce qu' il est
plus facile de trouver des trucs contre
ces capitaux d'onkyo contre
berlin bah écoute chacun qui sait bouger
les pièces ford et le virement parce que
au pire on sait les murs ouverture
donc cavale et ses 3 ou encore les f3
intéressant
on a laissé trop alors donc maintenant
sur ses habitudes bien sûr faux bond 4
pas intéressant colère 3 3 ou dans le
dos par tous on peut trouver des trucs
ici en fait à prendre des photos en tout
cas à gauche à droite au web
dans le sud bien sûr donc ici je pense
que tout le monde y compris icaro joue
petit rock avec les trois faux bouffe
dans ces trois de cinq tout le monde
fait samedi le match 2 granic anand donc
appuyer sur ça va être la même chose
aujourd'hui aussi pas de vulgarité à
vlad en entrée de ce crime là comme ça
pardon tadic ram mika nand
désolé c'est tout naturel ces sorties
vraiment nette également chez toi
oh la la mea culpa oui quelle faute
c'est ce que tu disais un os et des cinq
baies à ce jour et donc ça fait
depuis le moi qui voulais tenir du
chemin matin
sympa ça passe
mais il a dit mir dont le diminutif et
volodia épingle had
volvo l'audience non importants à peu
dire vous voir aussi
donc fou j'ai cinq tous à ses principes
et atypique typique de ces danses et 4
précise et mes amis il ya un truc jamais
j'ai jamais compris dans cette ligne
quand est-ce qu'il faut une loi ajoutez
h 6/4 et quand est ce qu'il ne faut pas
je n'ai jamais compris les différences
pour moi c'est
cette terra incognita recrue peut dire
que dans l'arago usine
quand on est haut dit qu'il faut
toujours rajouter dans l'argot zine
ben ali
il croit que
la six est questionnable parce que je
pense que eux ils se privent pendant
quelques coups à faire un super moment
donné ils le font donc mais de cb 600
fait si vous voulez seulement c'est
l'idée de yakov mais c'est alors j'y
suis pour tous les autres qui ont
développé ce avec quoi les noirs force
la dame de sortir là quelque part au
centre
lattaquié plus tard avec x 6 dont cagnes
de tempo avec puis donc
préparé ce 5 et alors comme ça donc
légaliser yole avantage d'oeuvre mois
contre donc la peur parce qu'au bureau a
vu un truc comme ça récemment
est ce que tu pense qu'il ya moyen
d'obtenir quelque chose ici pour les
blancs où tu sens la terre sèche non non
non pas du tout encore et ici il ya du
gros débat théorique il faut canadair
coup par coup parce que sinon on peut se
faire torturer il car il a l'air très
confiant on regarde
rien dire du dos premièrement je sais
moi je sais pas d'accord que l'être non
il l'air confiant
je sais pas
tu penses qu'il a l'air
déçu
moment où il est normal chose entre eux
par les orgues
je pense que
oui mais je peux me tromper
tu veux dire que fier roux
ne surprendrait pas aujourd'hui
mais c'est plus dur de surprendre avec
les blancs qu'avec les noirs non on
pourra toutefois
pas du tout
fait plaisir de retrouver
mes amis je
vais vous avouer les positions après
d'armes ce dock you avec les noirs les
noix
donc surprise
maintenant je chez pierre haski au
garrot ailleurs cette position précise
il a joué fois ci c'est en tout cas
on va reculer la dame ouvre la danse ces
deux
noms à thoiras qatar topic
il touche le x 6 salles intérêts oui oui
tout à fait ah aussi en fait à quoi qui
après tout ce que je peux faire la même
chose souvent carlo cavaliers se
déplacent plus tard sur 2,7 et de moyens
en métal et d'un sursis se bat pas ici
bien sûr
ici serait dur de jouer 15 et 17 juin
pour le meilleur et surtout d'un point 6
et tu fais quoi avec ton fief est tu
fais j'ai trois fous j'ai deux noms de
picchio de m
le plus souvent en jaugeant mac auliffe
3 3 ou 4 forfaits font
et puis j'arrive de trois-roches 2e ou
3e 2 et genre h3g quatre
noms gkd direct c'est qu'il ya une
partie a pas très longtemps pas dans
cette position tout à fait mais entre
goût caché souleymane ly à sharjah
il ya eu 1 à 3 pour temporiser après roi
qu'il avait fait un g4 non mais les g4
comme les h4 maintenant son analyse à
bolton importe quel point c'est pour ça
que je te demander ce qu'on peut penser
à cavalière 3 et 4 moi je preview mouais
bof n'empêche c'est possible mais moi
j'ai vu ou plutôt comme je dis donc on
relève trois et quatre roues ou 3 parce
que c'est une position ça pourrait
potentiellement marcher nager 4
oui mais pas souvent parce que je sens
qu'il faut je crois que les quatre plus
tard et on va essayer d'avoir un truc
c'est pas moi disons aux moines parlait
très abstrait moi parce qu'il sa dépend
de la peau du père disons ça en est où
ici 2 ici pas que je garde un goût tout
va être intéressant mais c'est pour
donner des coups simplement comme ça
et comme ça
comme sage se pose aussi
ça peut passer des fois quoi
il a fait dams est
est ce que là ça peut passer genre
direct
aux bosquette
ça pourrait s'analyser en vrai ça
oh oui vous voyez nombre c'est possible
bien sûr
je sais pas j'ai une myriade de coûts ce
5 je sens que
tours de 8 comme elle est de 7
ça peut s'analyser bien sûr mais ça ça
me donnerait si si ceci est ce qu'on
paris qui va avoir un g4 dans la partie
d'accord
d'accord je dit content jeudi pour jeu
contre à toi tu dis pour eux majdi ports
vont pondre un g4 va arriver
afin non pas au milieu de chou enfin les
attend non non pas au milieu du
championnat
je sais pas moi je vois ces normes
et les hôtes du jour
milieu de voeux
avec bonté largement favori si tu
enlèves la finale
nostra planus
ici
six fois makaio cette position dans sa
pratique chaque fois et le jeu tour de 8
et l'âge après tour du web
[Musique]
c'est ainsi qu'on ce que je passe pas et
pas trop de succès quoi toutes les
parties
il a eu deux fois ça avec rapporte
quand on demande comment on s'assure que
les joueurs qui partent triche pas
quand il part de l'échiquier commença
sur qui trichent pas
bon il ya des détecteurs métalliques à
l'entrée d'accord
parfois vraiment pas souvent il ya des
comment s'appelle jamais roues comme ça
en français commencent à peine ces
débrouillards ou et débrouillard pas
souvent mais cela s'applique aussi ici
il ya quand même de mettre de sécurité
qui regarde les gens - si vous voulez je
pense
pour quelqu'un vraiment bien équipé tous
ces mesures c'est juste rigolo ce juste
rigolo je pense que c'est très facile de
les surpasser et c'est en tout vraiment
je suis sûr de ce que je disais ok comme
d habitude
ico écart ou perde pas encore ils
répètent toujours ce que le feu devant
d'ailleurs sa très grande faiblesse
c'est très très grave problème il voit
toujours réputé ce qu'il a donné
le succès avant c'est un gâchis car à
moins que le père rien il cache le logo
qui est cliquée hikaru de savoie sont à
vue il a fait gaffe quand il l'a prise
ah non il l'a remis
au revoir à mon avis ça doit être ça
n'ont même pas des fouets panthers
forfait ou et
avant ça mérite non bah oui
oui oui les titres messieurs l'habitat
je reconnais à enghien
abba mon avis est là il faut demander si
à des arbitres dans le chat mais je
pense que pour ses qu'un peu comme tenu
non correctes tu sais que si tu es marié
ou quoi tu dois jouer oui par forfait
c'est pire que oui ou non
c'est même pire plus on rit puis quoi je
pense qu'il doit être ban de la partie
là
quoi il peut offrir du product payment
s'ils sont bons qu'à ferez quoi ici là
pays et surtout sur wii passe
salah il peut pas
mais m ned kelly reza une année de monde
est là ouais ouais ben jeff le coi a
d'ailleurs mes amis ici dans cette
proposition après tout
j'aimerais pire sur qui que ce soit je
adams deux contre zéro
c'est une nouveauté alors il veut quatre
noms
des piqûres d'un faux scoop aux hauts
cadres parce que kirin si tu peux
montrer
mais du coup aller en c2 directement et
qu'adam c'était si cons
oui moyenne et c'est là je sais pas
danser de danse etc allaient peut-être
les noirs jouent pas d'âme aux sept as
tu vois où est illusoire de bons projets
pas cavalier de 700 cas précis
parce que
oui
6 je pense que y avoir une partie comme
ça crame ni que kasparov beaucoup
beaucoup d'hommes sérieusement les
d'étudiants possède 5
à oui oui sur comme ceux ci se joue
encore les pauvres j'ai la rave de la
partie oui non pas
l'une des premières
vingt huit
ans et damas six échecs
et tour à ses huit mois c'est ça et
caraïbes et 8 c 5 1
j'ai retrouvé grâce alors dit je pense
c'était ça et donc du coup il a perdu un
tempo à ok il veut dire qu'il a perdu un
tempo mais que dams est est pas utile
quand même assez questionnable ce qu'il
veut sur ces cinq
lors diem pas du tout par contre
1 il ya une deuxième finesse je veux que
je te la dit quand tu fais de 4,5 g 5
qui ont froid f6 tu touches la dame
comment quand tu mets le pion aux 5 g tu
touches
[Musique]
qui peut être une différence
je re 4 fou prend effet un 3-points f1
et là y'a pas puis on prend des quatre à
cause de 5 donc tu vas être obligé de
faire j'ai 5
fu g3
d'amphoux g3 ça va pas et dix cavaliers
c6 donc il veut jouer quoi hein
il veut ça
le centre qui aimait ses équipes airshow
des 5e puis ils perdent autour de 6
alors puis tui pirlo pop
est compliqué très compliqué par exemple
le temps pour 1,8 comme ça je vais
peut-être qu elle et h7 surtout je
trouve peut-être un beau jeu alors
rechute
h41 ça dure ça dure ça dure pendant
ça peut être hyper compliqué
on va faire un petit tour sur les autres
échiquiers vlad au passage
assez radjabov avec les blancs
c'est quoi comme ouverture
catalan
ah oui oui la ligne archipopulaire
permet le jour 2 litres et maintenant
tout le monde joue ici soit que vous les
deux ans avait prévu à
beroun n'a pas avancé pour le moment
non ça joue toujours pas dans cette opa
firoud c'est un coup très très rares
jeux a cure trois fois à chaque fois pas
deux jours donc c'est sûr moison
et ding
ding
konyo konyo konyo cette somme rien c'est
la souveraine principal
d'aller greenfield de la variante ce pas
ce qu'ils font ces quatre au site il
faut que ça que je pense pas que ça ait
très joué près c'est très souvent
et du coup ils nous manquent pas il nous
en manque deux
cars wanadoo d'art ou la
wii c'est pour ça que j'aime
fanny fois biz coop c'est l'un des rares
qui peut se permettre d'aller
à l'attaquant gomez
défenseur
adrian déficit ans quand même
c'est pas de la même catégorie
et donc il nous reste
la partie qui nous intéresse
en tout cas n'a qu'à qui réfléchit
il connaît forcément non
non il a une idée sur ce qu'est ce qui
se passe sans aucun doute mais
peut-être et les analyser ça il ya trois
ou qu'il ya quatre ans je vois ce que je
veux dire est maintenant souvent en a
les évolutions différentes et le mali
elle est beaucoup plus et les
profondeurs mais j'ai dit ça beaucoup de
fois et ça fait longtemps mais il n'est
pas créatif il est pas efficace dans sa
préparation il répète qu ils ont pu
préparer il ya longtemps et à chaque
fois avant qu'il se fait défoncer puis
ça y est le vélo boulot commence à
écouter mais c'est pas moi qui ai dit
qu'il faut apprendre sur les x 2 autres
n'est-ce pas
donc dangereuse times bricard ou
pet et on est d'accord que l'ordi
confirme ce que j'ai dit ouais avec la
petite turbine est
complexe et sur cinq y avait pas pu on
prend 1,5 d'amc ronde et un pour prendre
et on en prend des airs d'impro cinq des
huit échecs à ses cavaliers ou huit qui
défend des
quoi tu prends sur fond parce que tu
peux prendre avis que le roi tu peux
prendre avec lui
mais c'est pas plus logique de prendre
avec le roi
parce que souvent après je sens que les
100 kg rouge 5 2 5 2 5 qui va peut-être
mais c'est hyper compliqué en fait
et c'est préparent assez sur une 57 pour
ali reza c'est sûr qu'il connaît
ouais c'est compliqué c'est très
compliqué comme position mais tu voi
alors dit déjà que dame 8 tu peut
pédaler pour comprendre
qu'avaient les b 17 tours j'ai trois
rois f8
damned
et suroît 8 pour essayer de partir f4
ouais t'as raison en fait c'est hyper
chaud
roi des 8 f
cavaliers prend
sisters problème 6 tours g8 s'est déjà
perdu
oui il ya d'autres lignes force et aussi
comme par exemple ce
5e quatre
fourgons dur front
je sens que les gens s'en cacher je sens
que c'est des
olives de ces délits d e f dans ce cinq
dames ce cinq blessés et tous brut après
hyper chaud d'ailleurs 3g 3g si ça peut
te rêver aussi
donc pour l'instant dans les banques y
ont de plus mais
très possible qu'ils vont les perdre
ça fait peur un petit peu avec eux les
noirs mais c'est bon c'est bon quoi
cette ligne là je comprends pas encore
ce coût exact
après ça peut être aussi joué sur le
fait qu' caron connaissent pas trop bien
parce qu'il allait sur une surprise
quand même ali reza
oui bien sûr - r
je dois dire qu'on n'a qu'à comme
quelqu'un qui est souvent surpris par
les auteurs de l'ouverture jeudi
/
il est habitué quand même de se
débrouiller sur l'échiquier
c'est pas qu'ils ont
couru c'est un choc et ce n'est qu' une
situation habituelle quoi ok une autre
fois il doit en plus il doit connaître
des
donc je parle ce - paquiot il voit trop
trop trop hésiter il va choisir si vous
ça aide on va sortir alors
ces réactions assez vives et bientôt je
pense me la série au nom pour l'instant
bien trop de le dire disons que pour
l'instant à vrai dire les lignes que je
vous ai montré les dernières où ça cette
chasse à charge et on est dans le final
je vois pas trop qu'est-ce que
même ouvrir au bio et
pardon il va pas trouver
car je peux pas dire que c'est si dur
que ça
non non en atos lui aux deux choses
mille fois plus le plus compliqué il va
perdre aujourd'hui car on
remet la cam en grand on va voir un peu
comment ils réfléchissent qu'il a enlevé
son étudiant relève pas son verre c'est
terrible il ya personne qui dit rien et
personne qui moufte
mais ça c'est quand même partie par
contre j'ai pas compris comment c'est
possible que c'est
permis à vous ça c'est incroyable en
vrai c'est incroyable
il est qu'ils aient oublié qu'il ait mis
là et qu'ils aient oublié c'est une
chose mais que l'arbitré viennent pas
l'enlever c'est quand même particulier
je te tire les arbitres on n'a pas été
au courant de son accord officiel avec
les filles 2 s'il avait un accord
spécial il lui répond enfin mais plus
tard j'ai servi deux passes et les arts
ils veulent pas le déconcentrer non oui
enfin bon si tu si tu commences à pisser
sur l'échiquier ya un arbitre qui va
venir fin j'ai enroulé un moment non ils
veulent pas le déconcentrer c'est pas un
argument
non c'est pas qu'ils veulent pas l'eau
et de quoi cette fois c'est plus que
vous êtes au moins version ce cas il est
signé quelque chose avec les fidèles et
les leaders ne pas au courant c'est
possible mais il y aurait dix mille cas
où il lui aurait dit au début de la
partie je garde mon vernon il a oublié
de dire avant les parties mais il a dit
après avoir fait quelques coups il
dit
à quoi ils prennent un beau veulent me
voir pourquoi
ça m'étonnerait quand même
en tout cas j'aimerais bien savoir parce
que c'est
c'est étonnant
on soit
normalement dans ces tournois là ils te
laissent pas
avoir un sponsor
extérieur comme ça en premier plan
c'est normalement c'est intolérable
d'ailleurs comme bruit il est très très
très souvent en os android
et avax juste en face de leur club juste
en face ça veut dire donc comme c'est
tout une petite rue il ya
15 m interdis crabe et starbucks après
si c'est pas son sponsor osef non ben
non ça tu veux pas faire de la pub fin
c'est juste que c'est très réglementé
ces choses là pour que les joueurs
puissent pas faire de la pub pour tous
pour rien pendant les tournois c'est des
choses qui sont réglementés dans le
sport parce qu'il ya d'autres sponsors
officiels que tu peux voir derrière el
país à la comunidad et madrid fait
family steinberg et de chasse comme et
du coup tu peux pas avoir des sponsors
qui s'invite comme ça au hasard sur les
images ce qui est tout à fait normal oui
kevin tu vois quand je dis il va pas
trop hésité il voit jouer ce qu il sait
doit être oui
c'est plus haut je suis plus ou moins
sûr que céline que j'espérais et puis on
va voir alors là la profondeur quoi
leucate
maintenant
pas
sinon si le noir arrive à jouer je crois
qu'on va laisser six duels voire
carrément mieux non oui oui j'avais pu
avoir bien trop de différences ou de vos
groupes mois et donc bon il faut il faut
se dépêcher quoi
4 mais bien sûr monsieur donc au fond
rouergue
contactera prend fin qu'en tira cette
finale qui viennent
du réseau les juristes de gagner le pari
du risque de gagner le bris propose que
bien probable on m'a donné il va devoir
vous insistiez ses pions sur l'île
durant
un nom par contre j'ai dit et pas dans
les faits mais leur maintien mais on
n'est pas encore en finale
bientôt
virus et pas la peine de partir très
loin il va pas tarder de brindas sur
fond de ballet il est obligé non le coup
donc méthode qui marche pour se détendre
ou et qu'on tente parmi nous
oui c'est lyon de façon de
se calmer mais
franchement c'est moi qui suis une
grosse goutte boinot
non je suis pas
battue c'est peut-être parce qu'il fait
chaud en fait
pour la pop jusqu'à présent sont
actuellement considère qu'on entre dans
une finale jamais un oui
moi il va faire comprendre façon ça
c'est vraiment obligé on veut pas se
laisser prendre en a six
les réflexions en tout cas
cette ligne avec des pseudos quatrième
jour depuis toujours en fait parce que
je pense que depuis quinze ans ça n'a
rien donné presque tout le monde mais
tout le monde l'a joue quand même tous
les mois que je joue quand même pourquoi
pas c'est toujours le rêve d'obtenir
quelque chose en risque à regarder en
fait pour ça que tout le monde sait et
reus et
je sais pas si aujourd'hui ça va sortir
de l'airé gelmer
ce presque toujours rien rien de rien
pour le banc il va je vous plains f1
c'est sûr mais pourrait réfléchir autant
surtout prend enfin parce que de toute
façon il a besoin ni les arbres réfléchi
parfois font réfléchir sont allés à
l'issic ans dès le deuxième tour déjà
donc
il ya deux choix pour les blancs
donc il pourrait clickfree f1 et
attendre de voir ce que fait ali reza
toi tu penses qu'un an plus tôt du roi à
nantes au tour parce que je suis sûr
qu'il est pas là pour juger trop
apprécié ce qu'elle voit et voyez ce que
tu penses qu'il a préparé ce matin non
non non
l'une de ses grosses mains message tu
veux dire qu'ils venaient risque il a
révisé ce matin mais les récuser puis en
surpoids ce que quand tu joues comme tu
es fort et tu joues contre maca tu peux
te sens voire pour cent sûr que tara
cette pause sur les chinois qui peut se
rappeler très très très très loin en
finlande joueurs les plus créatifs sur
l'échiquier est en fête donc oui c'est
l'un des joueurs les plus hauts
prévisible dans sa prépa quand elle joue
les deux les fois où il est très très
friands c'est par le manque de seconde
en où c'est par fainéantise personnel se
parlent à moi pour l'argent maintenant
que streamer c'est pas ça par amour et
donc de voir
c'est content qu'ils fabulent et par sa
fille niasse ou en volonté de se
préparer en amont donc par trois
facteurs si les archives a fait il ya
plein de delta bien comme cela que tu es
complètement sûr que tu vas avoir
contrevenu si tu joues avec les bornes
donc d'aller berlin dans le berlin
pareil ici paraît encore plus heureux au
bas si ils encaissent aujourd'hui [ __ ]
de revoir
modificés
[Musique]
chacun dans ce fiasco
après c'est pas facile de corriger ses
points faibles ça c'est hyper facile de
choses que tu pouvais 2,3 mec bien et ça
y est vous envoyer du nouveau staff quoi
chaque semaine et aucun problème
après peut-être qui se dit car j'ai
toujours la même chose dont il s'en
rappelle bien j'en sais rien moi presque
sûre et confortable pour lui sur dans le
sport et c'est moi ils ont trouvé pas
mal d'autorité vraiment intéressante
mais oui le répète comme j'ai pas
commis la free
a
maintenant encore il faut sans besoin de
réfléchir mais il voit faire je sens que
c'est forcément sinon c'est le 5 en fait
parce que
il n'ya pas que dame s'est troué sur la
pochette est aussi hélas tous sur deux
week qui se proposent sur le problème de
la main prochain
d'ailleurs c'est un truc j'ai remarqué
alireza j'aime bien qu'il le fasse c'est
quand il a sa prépa lui prend pas des
heures pour les foins f1 ou des coups
comme ça il joue vraiment quasiment un
tempo oui et d'ailleurs il a déjà fait
mais c'est un point fort ça il a tout à
fait raison c'est pas du tout les points
à 7 heures durée quand tu es à 100% sur
youtube aux fruits frais oui mais non
d'ailleurs souvent c'est pour tout le
monde parce que j'ai un élève à vicky je
me bat depuis deux ans déjà qui est un
thème travaux junkie céréales quoi et
donc non je voudrais penser de réfléchir
quand vous êtes sûr que vous allez
refaire le coup c'est la foudre en f1
par exemple il ya des coups parfois on
peut dire je peux me tromper ou quoi
mais la foudre en f1 c'est vraiment
obligé l'appareil pourtant pas certain
en vrai sur ces deux coups là il va
perdre quasiment sept ou huit minutes
bêtement en fait
mais qu'est ce que tu veux il
s'attendait pas du tout à ça il
comprendre qui au fur c'est pas
quelqu'un qui dans un tournoi comme ça
à dire que l'équipe comme il l'a c'est
pas quelqu'un qui va jouer n'importe
quoi il comprend que
les dilemmes
vous attend dans le futur proche où est
donc la studio peut-être il y arrive pas
à comprendre encore on sourit dangereux
et tu vois pas contre quelqu'un d'autre
il a fait tirer et les reflets tirer
hacked le clic quand même quoi
en gros en ce moment de là il hésite
quoi il hésite mais qui est ce qu'ils
ont pris part que je crois que tu es qui
dit les sept humide c'est typiquement ce
qui a manqué hier à faradje à boeufs
c'est vrai quand tu vois la partie a été
très mal autant avec 7,8 de plus si fait
j'ai 5 h 5 h 4 mais écoute quand tu es
un bon joueur de fnl jeu 5h kader al
cinq mois on m'avait que oui mais oui
c'est compte sur le poids face à ce qui
nous a manqué c'est forcément des
erreurs vlad un moment donné quand un
peu de temps on en fait tous pas de ce
genre pas de ce genre calcul louis
tactique oui mais le manque de
compréhension d'ailleurs chez radjabov
c'est connu depuis qu elle joue qui a
positionné le mas pas tout à fait ça
quoi c'est plutôt une surprise
ils les can you pour ça bien qu'en mer
assez confiant hikaru front
se joue plus haut je pense il voit pas
de problème bonjour et alors c'est quoi
votre préparer
tu penses qu'il a déjà cavalli bd cette
dame c'est cinq
jetons 4 avons 4 avant de 10%
et donc il doit pas comprendre pourquoi
c'est un problème ou e mail ou le
problème est alors
tu pense qu'il a raison
ouais
mais là il a forcément un truc alireza
il est
possible que ces gains il utilise une
méthode prem
dur de mettre en place - qui peut donner
des résultats fantastiques je sais
jeanne finale est égale mais plutôt de
là ils ont trouvé une vue une force qui
dure encore jamais ouï dire oui ça c'est
dur à faire mais oui si tu arrive c'est
bien ça et elle est le truc c'est que
oui c'est nul mais faute offre de faire
tousser au 8 juillet si tu fais ok je te
sert le monde sinon je te serre la main
mais pourtant c'est ce qu'on appelle un
freeroll en fait oui frérot le ferait si
tu trouves les 8-10 coup c'est nul on
serre la main et si tu trouves pas je te
bats ça c'est l'idéal c'est les
préparation idéale ouais c'est un peu ce
qu'avait fait caruana contre mvl
première partie notamment du candidat au
tofu est ailleurs dans cette base il a
d'ailleurs évolué la répéter la proche
d'une cadence est parti en
europe étaient les links you hell et le
jeu plusieurs fois romain bytes faut
punir normal
la nouveauté était quand même assez
élaboré un oui bien sûr il a fait g5
bien évidemment assez imprévisible
bien sûr mais c'était juste pour dire
c'est de préparer la particulièrement
elle était vraiment bien
joué de la part de fabiano
il va faire qui est rangée 5 tempo
j'imagine s'ils continuent
donc oui il a tout à fait raison de tout
bouffer collége 5 tout de suite avec
confiance parce que faut jamais oublier
le facteur psychologique ou bien sûr et
voyez clairement même sur alger heroes
temps qu'un petit peu
il est vrai
il ya deux sentiments cheikh aweys et il
a l'air d'être confiants mais en
interrogatif en même temps ces genres
comme tu le dis c'est genre qu'est-ce
que vous avez là parce que ça m'a l'air
d'aller ouais mais genre c'est quoi le
problème il a l'air de s'interroger
confiant mais dans l'interrogation
firoud il est vraiment tranquille où il
est vraiment très très bien préparés
pour ce tournoi quand même
c'est le sait la troisième journée
d'affilée qui semble à l'aise dans son
ouverture alireza même hier ils avaient
jusqu'à cinq tours à 6 topher ça s'est
pas très bien passé après dans le début
de la finale et cavaliers c6
en
ok si c'est pas même il va réfléchir bon
le coup qu'on a envie de regarder la 2e
bien sûr même s'il n'y a pas que ça qui
existe parce qu'il existe aussi un coup
comme ça par exemple paul avec les
démocrates on en veut rien avec 1 quoi
qu'il en soit wealth encore les 10-14
ils ont dames c'est maintenant
dans le sens d'un bus est avec les deux
dames au qatar
ici deux ou trois que les sodas donc
c'est l'idée du chaos
alors le 5e volet de 4,1
[Musique]
d'embrun par exemple
dans beauce est paré
aux fauves six dames jeu de
29,6 en bouffe sur dix huit
toujours debout fois sur dix huit en
gardant toujours cette possibilité de
donner chaque sur f3 et rod par exemple
à temps il a joué tempo d'un ancien
danseur nouvelle c'est qu'il a way
maintenant alors
il n'y en a eu cinq écoles et d'icade
santé pour six cavaliers de 4 à le
problème bien sûr ces dames offre 4g
c'est pourquoi jacques et sicoval et 2,5
d'alger 4 et est finie
ah oui
ici dans ma fuite au lieu de 2008
wissmann oui oui ici dans mon fils d'un
mafieux
alors
donc dans ce sens il doit faire quoi
c'est une menace gravement la coupe de
moscou en russie
il doit faire cinq lui-même 5 alors ok
à dessein car l idée 4
mais bon tour des 3 et puis ça peut être
que le début d'heure ou peut-être pas de
5 me fourchette 14 points parce que
comme ça menace dame de 5 ou à damas six
et sur sa
wii d'un mois 5
non non la bouffe et c'est pas
intéressant qui à charge contre les
pions
religion plus
mais y'a tour d'essai puis au faubourg
tours 8 trois singles
avant on peut pas terminer sur ce pôle
mais il est vrai c'est pas très
intéressante peut-être dans le 5e set
parce que après dans la synchro
chaussettes on n'a pas le temps de
monter la tour sur détroit parce que
dans mon cas
alors
après 5 plutôt de 5 je suppose
est maintenant au tour de trois et ça
commence
écoutez je vois ce qu'on a de bonnes
raisons d'être content pour passer une
bonne ouverture c'est bon ça a l'air
d'être hyper compliqué
et hikaru il n'a pas l'air de connaître
c'est une partie vraiment importante
pour les deux d'ailleurs
toutes les parties sont importantes mais
à carreaux à peine revenu dans le
tournoi je pense que s'ils repèrent
aujourd'hui ça va vraiment lui mettre la
tête
dans le sac et alireza avec les blancs
il doit absolument mettre la pression au
moins une première journée
skis car on va réfléchir longtemps ici
questionnable parce qu'il ya quoi comme
les coûts aussi tout reprend des 4e tour
des quatre cavaliers de 4 et 5 oui mais
pas d'un f4
auquel acda mais cette fois ci ce cas
ici 2 2 qui a validé quatre lords
ambassade en bessin coin
d'un bois 5 et 6 roues f3
dans deux trois ou quatre dames
f-15 ici d'un méchant ici dame échec roi
ici d'un échec
je
tu vois pas sur possède à l'heure tu
vois sur bo5
après damas
il est aux héros ainsi par exemple
dans ma 4 watts cette dame de cette fois
ci c'est
complexe
sans compter sur cavani ces deux là
aussi roi des huns
d'ailleurs en fait on s'est perdus qui a
essayé de roi des
as c'est pour ça que c'était dame 17
d'abord ouais ouais bien sûr c'est pas
évident
ça ça semble un nul en force en fait
non pas du tout
en fait on peut aussi faire roi des deux
ici d'un mets fins et re rentrer dans ce
truc là c'est en fait c'est hyper
compliqué
ouais c'est quoi la différence
hu a besoin un roce 2 continue oui oui
ça ça peut te passionne pour les blancs
non mais ça alors dit la boutonné 00 oui
oui ça ressemble à la vérité à ses
récents modèles eric tu menaces dame c4
damak hattmatt déjà et sur dame 3 roide
le roi est cachée c'est lui qui est
faible et non ça c'est mieux pour les
planter ou plus probablement fait là
c'est la préparation voit on voit les
après pas parfaite ça c'est la
pré-soirée ce qu'on appelle
les noirs puent le jeu et 6 à ossun
partout peut-être 107e il faut connaître
très très très très loin voilà les lie
avec les pros pas parfaite et l'eau
par les bois
et les répétitions des bonnes fautes par
la camorra coup
à écouter aujourd'hui je pense que un
peu souffler beaucoup plus haut même on
allait les brémois kyo
les deux jours avant quoi on a les
blancs de la bouffe calmes aujourd'hui
c'est pas les mêmes quoi on allait blanc
c'est pas le moment ce prix que
sur le stream en anglais ils disent
qu'il ya 15% de chances qu ali reza et
analyser la position mais ils sont
complètement fous ils jouent tous tempo
15 non mais bon ils sont complètement
taré en fait il ya moins de poids 3% que
le banaliser non mais c'est 99% fait
9 9 9 9 9 9 9 et il ya toutes les
chances que lui a préparé ce matin
pendant des heures non mais c'est sûr en
2h quoi
sert obligé qui enfin ils jouent tous
tempo il y aurait ce 1h54 il a réfléchi
six minutes pour 17 coups pour jouer 18
coups dans une position hyper compliqué
après cavani c6 il a joué dames c'est un
tempo alors que
l'éventail des coûts possibles étaient
assez large mais les taux d'audience
existe souvent en fait je peux me
permettre de montrer en ligne elle est à
la mode il dit 5,58 un gars qui comprend
pas l'anglais en fait ils ont dit 50%
pas 15 fifty pas fifteen mais même
shifty c'est un
4 4 c'est dur adacore au quai henri iv
je peux mais là comme ça
et e5 que relève trois corps et ses 6 x
5,6 x 4 que les six tués records ou 7-5
6-3 petit rock des quatre fois c'est fou
de 5h 6h 4e 2 est maintenant au lieu de
cinq
je sens que tu sers à huy gros turc et
attendre ce sens et inquiets
peut-être le coup principe un hollande
des coûts principe justement avec les dg
5 maintenant quand les 100 kg dames je
sens que comme ça elles renforcent les
pressions sur six sous et donc d'un seul
en tant que l'idée c'est pas à bosser un
grand classique non c'est pour meubler
ou et est ce que ça se ferait pas avec
un petit shooter gingembre cette prépa
je pense que quand tu prépares ça vaut
mieux de ne pas boire un petit shoot de
jan jambon plus tôt d'où tu es comment
s'appelle
t un fusil une fusion gabon s'est calmée
quoi parce que tu es déjà trop excité
que le shoot ou et le soudan n'a pas
besoin des fois un couple plutôt calme
et bon esprit qui voit enlever encore tu
veux une infusion
moi non c'est pas moi qui a préparé
cette ligne donc moi je vais en tout à
fait quoi du coup c'est une petit résumé
de l'ouverture pour les gens qui
suivront ce fait le résumé en une minute
au web
et après le shooteur à tout à faire
alors à fuir au à
cette fois-ci compris view d'ailleurs à
sortir des quatre parce que ici nakamura
khelil pour prévisible et plus fragile
que dans son bilan donc pour les
premières fois dans sa vie et la sortie
nîmes zoo avec dans le dos qui en
appelait les variantes à l'équipe d'irak
à trois fosses trois dames ces trois des
cinq c'est ce que les joueurs d'élite jo
dépit et jean n'a plus que dix ans déjà
maintenant faut que cinq de ces dans ce
cas précis pourquoi cette ligne ici à la
mode pour les noirs posca et elle est
destinée de utiliser les plus grandes
faiblesses de cette ligne pour les
bandelettes en blanc doit sources bien
trop tôt pour exposer trop exposé donc à
cette fois ci c'est le noir vont de
pouvoir exploiter sa foi 6 d'un macaque
dans cette ligne là je comprends jamais
quand est-ce qu'il faut jouer à
chisseaux pas où il a joué à six mais
parfois quatre dames hausse est beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de partis comme ça
qu'on arrive trois tours de 8 maintenant
même si quatre est passible ma mère
sakho dernier quart ou à carreaux à une
cette position si fo a déjà dans sa
carrière grosse faute de répéter ça ici
dans le dos presque jamais joué qu en
2021 trois fois par des jeux inconnus
par contre c'est très intéressant parce
qu'un chic dynamique les bons vieux
après ces 5 et 4 font tout et font
plutôt que roi et font parce que le tour
va être utile sur la colonne f plus tard
les bons vieux envoyer la pièce
approchait 100 400 kg poule 5 avec des
idées quoi donc 6e 5 par exemple
des des 5 et puis la tourmente sur
troisième aussi non f4 et donc un frappe
sur m6 oui les joueurs car les c6 assez
précis le coût et le plus précis après
dans sa il signe à réfléchir ils
s'attendaient plutôt à eux sans qu'ils
se posent mais dans l'ensemble c'est
nettement plus fort maintenant donc elle
est incarnée très bien les fichiers qui
dure encore peut-être en goût l'auteur
joue lui-même sur moi maintenant et
peut-être des buts de coude voilà merci
vlad se condenser cette explication à
express et ça bien mérité le petit shoot
et ajoie n'a plus d'autre une vingtaine
d'autres s'il te plait je vais chercher
tout ça
voilà moi à vrai dire un jeu de tests
de me retrouver à la place dos et courra
et hikaru maintenant parce que je me
rappelle qu'un une fois je jouais
l'homme le point a bien en suisse
je compte treize athlètes rejoint kerry
qui ne leur est pas présent tout est à
14 ans et je jouais lyon domaine
variante préférée donc les variantes et
youssef de l'espagnol je suis toujours
pensé que je suis un grand spécialiste
souligne la cua et au bruit et donc en
intérim est dans une position et quand
mes connaissances sont terminées et je
savais que ce juste égal ce doit être
nul ces analyses qui ont commencé donc
il a ajouté les coups comme ça encore
pendant très longtemps donc et bien sûr
ça a été nulle et la forme mais je les
ai pas je n'ai pas trouvé les pires duo
donc si vous voulez compteur raoui plus
ses potes donc elle est née et c'est
l'un de ses amis où il ya de cela je me
rappelle plus comment ça peut s'appeler
cette série télévisée voilà donc cd&v
les gars quoi ou de sega
vous voyez oui oui c'est bien ce garçon
quoi voilà donc je sais à quel point ce
désagréable première m'avoue s'avouer
qu'ils ont en gros bon vous pouvez vous
sauver mais peut-être pas pour pas plus
et puis donc vous savez qu'il faut donc
vous voulez marcher sur le chemin très
étroit quoi ça se dit comme ça marche et
ce n'est trois traits sur le joint très
très étroit et comme ça pendant
longtemps bref comme je vous ai dit
c'est cesser leurs sentiments pour cette
approche-là qui ont pas mal de gens ont
une expérience et déjà non non non à
vous mes amis je vous conseille pas
quand même de répéter toujours les mêmes
choses ils voyaient peu importe votre
niveau il voit est arrivé qu'ils qu'un
gamin
qui va vous mettre ce qui au fil rouge
est en train de mettre maintenant
et maintenant il va devoir passer par
les chemins boueux laïque à rebours pour
faire nul
tu as joué contre le pen
a c'est parce que j'ai dit lorenzo
bienne le pen les blagues et les
toitures donc prudemment juste qu'il n'a
pas compris en fait sur estiment en fait
une guerre manger n'engendre manger un
morceau de pain il a au passage ben haj
et
tu sûr ici me le chat web 10 marcher sur
un fil
bon ben maintenant on peut remettre en
grande gamme histoire d'avoir un peu
hikaru suez non à huy a plus j'adore
j'adore parce que les tellement
expressif l'été le mode comique quoi
parce que par exemple je pense que
carlson un moment donné à fond et ne pas
dire à quelqu'un à faire une pâte lisse
n'est sûr car sinon je pense que ça n'a
eu aucun succès parce que je n'ai pas
fait exprès si on pourrait faire une
bande dessinée sur les carreaux sur
hikaru tout offrir tout à faut bien sûr
c'est un héros d'une bande dessinée tout
à fait et tu sais qu'il ya quatre ica
n'est pas que oui car ou
est ce nom là aussi qu'un brin icap long
et y calvitie important
et kateri qu'à la ceca brin aujourd'hui
mais il faut le battre quatre fois pour
gagner la partie
c'est vrai que après un coup de
lacharrière
on peut croire qu aujourd'hui sera
marché parce que hier dire que en
changeant nos t shirts ne donne rien
dire après la difficulté c'est qu'il a
deux chevaux et il est très fort avec
les cavaliers y carrousel
[Rires]
important cette fois 4e
degré mais pas que
des fois je pense à écart ou la nuit
à
dire qu'à sa main droite et la fois un
geste que je peux te dire qu'il veut
bouffer avec le cow boy il va faire
qu'il prend des 4es je suis d'accord
avec toi j'ai pensé la même chose
il qu'à repousser sa transformation
ultime ouais si tu vois ses cheveux
changer de couleur malade
c'est que son niveau augmente
c'est ecafé aujourd'hui bien trouvé
il vient avec sa boisson starbucks café
il a du mal à jouer un coup ical
il arrive que pendant des heures de
stream en fait on ne fasse que ce genre
de blague
qu'il est très bien préparée car oneapi
calcul surtout
en fait ça peut ça peut ne jamais
s'arrêter
ok je j'ai regardé un peu avec leur dire
il va pas s'en sortir
parce que ça dure trop bon ça dure l'ont
à chaque fois ça dure l'ont donc on ne
voit pas ça fait un moment donné un bon
enfant il va peut-être s'en sortir au
niveau de résultat de la partie mais il
va pas égalisé
hockey
caracol pas en tête c'est pas possible
je lis le chat parce que c'est bien trop
haut niveau
là ça va trop loin en fait
icap
[Musique]
[Rires]
j'en peux plus petit lycée de chatte
icop autres et 4 comporte aucun capote
comme capoter le verbe
c'est capoté c'est quand même quelque
chose qui marche pas ah non c'est vrai
je connais c'est juste le mot capote
10 cartes
mais d'ailleurs il car c'est ni karpov
et kasparov
il capable en cas beaucoup de champions
du monde qui avait le cas dans leur
nom
mais faudrait qu'il s'appelle en fait
karuna caméra
ça y est on les a réveillés tôt à gaza
et enfin des 10 des discussions
intelligentes dans ce chat
là ils sont très très bons
en sortir donc il ne reste plus qu 1h08
en attendant c'est vrai qu'ils
commencent à ok il est pas mal autant
mais
ça commence à faire
oui c'est une fois assez extrêmes du
masochisme
d'ailleurs ce pauvre homme d'honneur de
différence ouais mais ça commence à
faire une vraie différence la haie
d'honneur c'est beaucoup
altis vu qu'aux joueurs c'est pas énorme
mais tu te rappelles que contre radjabov
pour pierrot jazz c'était pareil et tout
d'un coup
il s'était mis à le rattraper pour pas
grand chose
j'espère que la montagne ne va pas
accouché d'une souris
attention il va forcément jouer cavalier
prendre un set et prend des cats et le
coup qu'ils allaient passer ça
dans tout va en fait non et paraît que
tout va mais à chaque fois elle frôle
les faux frères des cons
mais comment il a pu apprendre autant de
choses à lire les images c'est ça qui
m'impressionne comment ils peuvent se
rappeler d'autant
ouattara quand
et aucun problème
ce qu'on est d'accord qui se rappelle de
tout ça pour une seule partie
oui bien sûr mais il coûte déjà
peut-être il a joué quelques parties
d'entraînement
contre quelqu'un qui n'est pas au
courant de cette nouveauté est longue il
peut les olympiques et la no 2 j'en
écoute toi tu me joue cette ligne
principale ou et à un moment donné je
vais te sortir un truc que je veux voir
comment tu veux réagir et donc donc là
donc il a eu deux parties a vraiment
appuyé bien sûr il a répété le fichier
plusieurs fois et ce montant là donc si
tu le sais devrait être relativement
facile quoi c'est facile
bah écoute quant à tout préparer c'est
pas que
quinze minutes avant la partie je sais
pas qu'est ce que tu as joué
c'est incroyable c'est le droit qui
quand on a demandé par exemple caleçon
et skycargo va se qualifier maintenant
et j'ai dit non je vois mal les carreaux
de se qualifier dans ce tournoi oui tu
penses que les tic pour les finales de
nogaro pour d'autres choses aussi
bien sur les finales c'est pas sur le
problème a déjà ses finales sont mieux
qu aux chiffres ou quoi oui il a parlé
sur moi par exemple de ce que je dis
c'est que je pense qu'il le connaît
encore oui il a des faiblesses à ces
grosses
tout cas là je pense qu'il sait pas ce
qui va jouer très franchement autant
tout à l'heure on avait l'impression
qu'ils avaient un coup là il en vrai
hésitation
il l'a vu qu'après cavaliers quatre
dames par maaf 4 et le bourgeois qualif
sent qu'il a vu ça et ma part il a vu ce
que l'ordinateur voix quand les
décadents dame aux quatre relève st il a
tout ça et qu'on quoi ok fc pas c'est
pas un très grand problème mais
maintenant elle a vu qu'après turdu
autour de 8 les bourgeois f3 avec les
devs se cacher sur yves douloureux et
c'est que le début
d'ailleurs les banques préparent jeu 4e
et
est pas bien saisi roi choisit sur moi
je sais dire toujours sander est sûr qu
elle est de 5 hier à fossettes kovalev 4
au food
pour ça d'ailleurs un abri sûr de lui
très vite
pour que la tour soit en prison que la
brochette soit toujours efficace les
brochettes sur les diagana lâche 4 dude
j'espère que mes propos sont
compréhensibles pour le spectateur donc
on peut dire qu'il a chaud où est donc
il a vu aux 3 4 et puis un jour il a eu
chaud
sur son mariage canicule
connu que sur ceux d'en bas mais
non c'est chaud pour lui en fait
et karine carette
comment vous dites les gars englewood
canicule et cani que le week-end que là
ça se dit comment canicule en russie
d'ailleurs voilà il n'ya pas un autre
mot très fort c'est le jardin mais jara
c'est pas précis pour canicule aussi
jarrassé quand il fait très chaud
ok
ça sort à
faire ces choix sont faits afin qu'elle
est fort et ses brûlures ouais ouais
c'est vrai ça surprend
et maintenance d'après sa gestuelle on
ne sait pas quel culot non
peut-être les changer d'avis
c'est marrant comme visible et moi si
carrie tête s'il fallait vraiment
modifié
elle est très belle désolé veille
j'étais obligé de la relever parce
qu'elle était très très belle il ya
d'autres tendances qui se bat
hikaru maintenant
d'un côté il est archi stressé
on sait pourquoi et de l'autre côté il
veut montrer quand même qu il est
confiant
et stressé pas possible oui bien sûr
c'est pour les prairies cas où on sait
très bien que
il cache mal son jeu
c'est tendu là pour le joueur américain
on voit qu'ils calculent des lignes
quand même et non il est pas bien
quand tu fais ça généralement c'est que
tu
turzi day we wept sais que tu repars du
début quand tu fais ça
quoi
là il doit avoir un truc moi je connais
les voiles quoi
car moi
c'est vraiment un finies les blagues
[Musique]
bravo à fuir ou de la mifi rouillac est
ce qu'il est bon en ouverture
puis roux et les gars et ses garçons
ouais mais là il apprend aussi bien sûr
c'est assez incroyable en fait celle
inverse de maxime
oui c'est juste l'inversé est ce que
maxime il est tellement bien dans les
finales et pour être précis et au delà
il est un peu moins précis ou quoi mais
il est
plus sur les ouvertures
moi je rappel sur les gens un fidèle à
une seule ouverture ouvrir leur appel a
vraiment donné qualif mans se prononcer
devant nous il était déjà très connu et
respecté notre toujours entrer
avant autour de oui oui il nous est dit
mais écouter mais pourquoi voulez jouer
très souvent vous voulez jouer contre
des gars est à dire là je prends mon
retour et rien d'autre comme je parle si
vous voyez votre copine ici les
variantes marche pas c'est une tragédie
pour vous ce qu'on mangeait pas votre
enfant vous lâchez vous mais c'est quoi
le truc comme toujours ce cheikh où vous
jouez à la neige dure
comment votre joue samedi la neige douce
ou les échecs y avait une métaphore en
fait
lié à la copine qui a lâché tout va pas
si sûr je crois que j'ai compris
de quoi il parlait à
et donc du coup il recommande d'avoir
plusieurs ouvertures ou sinon juste une
chose que bon tu joues parce que est
comment dire c'est que doit marcher
parce que tout un beau à tomber amoureux
de
badoo moreau de ce que
vivent le pour tunis mon chèque ouais
j'ai compris je crois tu vois j'ai
compris la philosophie
de tuffeau et la de la cavalerie
commence après le
week-end en fait
est-ce que capable
je crois ce qu'il a voulu dire non
autant écrire ou en vrai ça commence 59
minutes pour 22 coups dans une partie
position comme ça ça commence à
mal autant c'est pas le mot mais ça
commence a pu être super
vous comprenez il ya trois au minimum
qui marche il faut choisir mais à chaque
fois ça dure ça dure ça dure c'est dur
oui ça l'est parce que si on compte les
variantes le nombre de variantes en
général qui doit calculer ça va être
énorme fossé que ça dure ça dure et
c'est dur oui voilà away et d'ailleurs
c'est peut-être pire qu'il en ait trois
qui marche bien toujours bien sûr bob
c'est beaucoup plus pure est donc l ael
camp par l'un à l'autre et donc réguler
millau bat en fait
bateau de son bon moyen à chaque fois
selon
hicham vous fait pas tellement bien ses
émotions
comment thiam vous pas tellement mi
séance et les bourses ils font
[Rires]
bien le verbe camoufler eux
comme on foule
ça doit être un calvaire pour lui cette
position
pronostics il va pas s'en sortir
non là ça paraît vraiment compliqué et
surtout qui se fout vraiment mal autant
que dans ces situations là le plongent
qui réfléchit le plus en fait tu te
rentre dans le trou du jour à pitre
déjà pain
mais mais je dois dire aussi qu'au bout
d'un moment quand tu réfléchis tu il ya
trop de variantes et que ton jeu tron
dans la profondeur les choses
commençaient un peu se mélanger dans la
tête c'est pour ça que c'est aussi dur
de jouer de continuer à bien calculé
après cinq six heures de jeu après ça il
faut aussi dire que c'est le point fort
di caro qui réussit à continuer à
calculer pendant des heures et des
heures sans jamais baisser de rythme
mais en soi pour un joueur plus normal
ça
ça impacte vraiment physiquement de
passer autant de temps à calculer parce
que les lignes se mélangent les
positions se mélangent et à petit à
petit on perdre de la lucidité
on commence à avoir plus de mal à
évaluer les positions avoir du mal à les
comparer et on peut se perdre en fait à
force
on va voir si
s'il va réussir à faire mentir
cette prédiction
on dit généralement et que quand on
réfléchit plus de 40 minutes pour un
coup on fait une erreur après là comme
l'a dit vlad les en fait les trois coups
logique je crois tour des quatre
cavaliers des quatre ou cinq semble
pouvoir aller avec un jeu parfait donc
il peut pas vraiment se tromper mais le
truc c'est que c'est que le début pour
hikaru et ça il ne s'est pas forcément
d'ailleurs à quel point c'est que le
début peut-être qu'ils pensent qu'une
fois qu'il a trouvé ce coup lui en fait
dans sa tête il peut se dire il ya trois
coups possibles et on a un des trois qui
est bon si je trouve celui là après je
vais m'en sortir ça va être plus fort c
mais le truc c'est que c'est vraiment
une prépa du calibre de caruana
mvl et quand on pensait qu'elle veut
elle s'en était sorti en fait il y avait
encore une deuxième et une troisième
couche pour
pour vraiment
égaliser et c'est le problème auquel va
être confronté hikaru ici
donc ça c'est là c'est vrai que pour lui
c'est pas une bonne nouvelle
surtout que c'est une partie très
importante un elles le sont toutes dans
ces candidats mais il perd la première
il gagne la deuxiè me revient contre
radjabov avec les blancs qui est le
meilleur appariement qu'il aura tout au
long du tournoi donc il s'est remis à
flot s'ils repèrent aujourd'hui ça va
être difficile même si c'est un joueur
qui a d'énormes ressources
psychologiques
c'est difficile de toujours devoir
revenir dans le tournoi
ma position est vraiment très complexe
on pourrait écrire un livre sur cette
partie
en tout cas je suis très impressionné
par le niveau et la profondeur de
préparation d'ali reza i là je le
rappelle que 19 ans et un jour c'était
son anniversaire hier et on peut
imaginer
s'ils continuent sur cette lancée qui
kills et des préparations du niveau de
caruana ou karl scène pour le futur donc
s'il réussit à
à combler ses lacunes en finale il va
très très clairement être un cran au
dessus et il sera il s'installera dans
la durée dans le top 3 mondial voire
même mieux mais il faudra quand même
régler ce problème récurrent finale
alors qu'on voit là hikaru inquiet mais
contents de ce qu'ils calculent ils
aimeraient bien trouver quelque chose
qui va jusqu'au bout du bout mais comme
ici il n'y a pas de solution vraiment
pour assécher la position il va devoir
prendre une décision et il a du mal à
prendre à mon avis il a peut-être déjà
changé une ou deux fois d'avis alors
peut-être qu'il est revenu sur son coût
initial mais mais c'est sûr qu'il est
passé de cavaliers prend à tour prend ou
deux tours prend à eux cinq l'un des
trois coups que vous voyez à présent sur
votre écran
elle a très clairement
la décision et est difficile
s'ils savaient que les trois marches en
fait il en prendrait un wazari
réfléchirai après
quel a été le match le plus intéressant
pour le titre de champion du monde dans
la défense pour carlson clairement celui
contre caruana
ouais c'est la difficulté et caro qui
revient toujours sur les sur les mêmes
ouverture comme le disait vlad et il se
retrouve avec une préparation xxl et ça
c'est le genre de préparation qu'on
n'aurait pas vu dans un tournoi de
moindre importance 1 c'est la différence
entre ces tournois pour le pour le titre
mondial en fin du cycle pour le titre
mondial et les autres
je n'arrive pas trop à comprendre à quoi
sert la télé là en fonde
en fond d'écran
parfois il arrive qu'ils mettent les
positions des parties mais là ils ont
juste lui le logo de la fidh j'ai du mal
à comprendre l'intérêt profond de ce
téléviseur
alors sa propre et caro n'est pas un
fait la sof il n'est pas illégal max
ils
aiment ce jeu des ics à
saint georges avait impressionné que ça
durait plus que 10 minutes ah ben tu
peux le faire voler le abbaoui mais elle
est trop belle
elle est trop beau ce délire il ya une
miniature aussi avec les cats rica avec
ludwig qui a fait un montage photo tu
vois icaro en blond et caron roues
en fait c'est à l'e3 les quatre ica et
les 3 et 6 et 6 pièces qu ici pianca
épicier n'co
eux ils sont que trois c'est pour ça
qu'ils ont perdu contre les quatre
mais tu vas depuis le moment où on
pensait qu'ils allaient jouer cavalier
prend des quatre j'ai regardé il lui
restait une heure 3 et 40 secondes il a
reperdu encore treize minutes
t'inquiète et il va cumuler dois encore
perdre heures 30
on a eu un joli aussi ica corp mais là
qu'accorde tu dois pas connaître c'est
un phénomène
français dans league of legends c'est
une équipe légendaire de league of
legends ils vont remplir l'alleud ils
ont fait un guichet filon et je crois
qu'ils sont à guichet fermé pour
l'accord arena qui est le stade
du racing au rugby en ile de france et
je crois qu'il ya seize mille places ou
quelque chose comme ça on aura un match
de league of legends
a beaucoup de supporters de l'acca corp
ici dans le chatt forcément ils vont me
peuvent te faire un mur bleu ils font
des murs bleu de temps en temps on va
voir si assez de jeu supporters
qu'accorde tu vas voir un mur bleu qui
va apparaître sur le chat sait pas s'ils
vont le tenter
via une petite regard et une tentative
de mur bleu regarde où ont ils peuvent
envoyer un mur bleu à tout moment ils
sont très très nombreux
sur la même quand ils sont pas à
domicile
des murs bleus peuvent partir
et quand ils sont dans quand ils jouent
les tournées qui sont dans les salles
ils ont des petits des petits bouts de
papier bleu il est l'élève ils font des
murs bleu c'est sympa
l'accord arenas et une salle très bon
peu importe mais il ya beaucoup de place
alors aujourd'hui
garde plainte skull perrotin j'ai
confondu l'accord arena avec avec la
défense à rennes un peu importe ses
grands quand même c'est très grand
donkey cacahouète non mecacorp y gagne
normalement donc non en fait c'est pas
du tout et cas corp
bon
continuez à tank et un
nom là il va jouer il va jouer il
regarde la feuille il est dès qu'il va
envoyer un coup au hasard
bien six carottes sont cuites
ycare antenne aux championnats du monde
de blitz oui c'en était très heureux
là il va jouer il va jouer vad ça y est
il a mis sa main au dessus d'une pièce
lire touche ses lèvres là il va envoyer
il va falloir qu'il soit solide carapace
bah écoute ci pour trouver une bonne
réaction mais le toi même toucher ses
lèvres c'est que c'est pas un bon signe
des livres certains d'autres choses de
pitié
à voir s'il réussit vlad
trouver le coup monte à ça près il
pourrait lui donner un conseil jouer un
coup du jeu d'échecs
je pense comme quand tu es dans une
telle situation vaut mieux qu as tu
choisi juste regardé une seule variante
et approfondir ne met pas les trois en
même temps j'ai
d'autres choses et une vie
et
la terre en fête la terre
je suis à terre
ce chat est vraiment trop fort là je
suis vraiment à terre
il est d'environ je pensais qu'ils
allaient jouer vraiment pas ce qu'il a
il a un peu levé la main il est revenu à
extrêmement proche de sa bouche et
irréfléchie de nouveau mais peut-être ça
parce qu ils voient que fuir ou regarder
c'est pour stresser féroé
quatre fois sa voix que je joue c'est
qu'il y avait une fois je me rappelle
aussi dans le château ycare glace réparé
qu'un glace remplace vie ça tu peux pas
avoir parce que tu regarde pas la télé
ici
c'est vraiment fait rire
comme il fait beau coup de pub
allez il envoyait tout reprend
alors
tour des quatre
impôts
cavaliers prend et 2004 c'était ça ou
web et là c'était dame 17
et tu te rappelles c'était que le début
ouais c'était fou preuve six cavaliers
c-232 d'un bébé sans croix des deux
sites et sa dame et fin d'un objet trois
rois et fuite dame g7
roi 8 dames g8 3,17 damev c3 c6 dame
e63 b53 c2 et sur le groupe réfute ça
lui coûterait fuite mais ça y va pour le
jouer assez vite hikaru
jure pas tous réfutent mais la série de
coups avant
bah moi même on y apprend toujours aussi
non là c'est hyper compliqué mais je
sais pas qui est mieux les blancs
sûrement mais
non peut-être ça doit se tenir mais il
ya point tu joues encore et
on voit pas de risque au moindre les
perpétuent voilà faire toujours la
sas a
un truc comme d'indicateurs
et 6h
4a et la paix rhdp m
[Musique]
mais bon on n'est peut-être pas au bout
de nos surprises
il a joué et on prend des cadres déjà
qu'ils avaient des pros on va laisser
les coups
se jouer flat parce que ça devrait aller
assez vite
en fait là y'a pas que d'un f4 d'après
leur dis aussi f3
mais moins froid c'est bizarre
bref c'est sûr qu'elle y rezaï connaît
encore
marrant qui ont l'esprit des américains
il ne donnait que 50% pour ali reza
dans la hisser encore c'est sûr
pourquoi cinq gagne pas
à
c'était dame b 7 sur cinq
dames eu trois quarts lycées deux
des rois des deux qui avale et b3
oui mais là il y avait le piège aussi
car alice et de direct marche pas parce
qu'il ya roi des deux et que ça c'est
mieux au blanc roi des huns
oui il faut expliquer que par watt de
deux parce que l'eia colocataire
est
comme ça pour le
quel bordel pour icare où tu penses
qu'il l'avait d'un f4 oui c'est sûr mais
peut-être que c'était pas c'est pas la
seule chose qu'il a vu
mon metz juste
se trouvent abri mais
déjà perdu vraiment beaucoup de
l'énergie déjà les donc c'est beaucoup
moins évident que pour nous tous qui
regarde l'écran mais parce que là ça
fait vraiment une heure et quart qui
karun calcul quasiment non-stop et il
peut pas récupérer parce qu'il joue
tempo fqu et pendant tout ce temps là
il devrait avoir pour moi je défends ton
oui oui bien sûr voilà il m'a vu
peut-être une bonne dizaine de jeux
voilà il faut faire corps et les cheveux
pour un mince
c'est pas de chance
c'est dommage
c'est quand même dommage
c'est pas de bol eut pas de chance il
hésite encore
et en plus cavalier ces deux je crois
que c'est beaucoup moins fort c'est donc
ça va lui laisser beaucoup plus de coups
pour arriver jusqu'au 40e parce que là
on est au 20e et la séquence avec dame
17 c'est quasiment forcé jusqu'au camp
30e il ya dix coups force et avec tous
les échecs qu'on a vus mais là s'il ya
que 3 4 coups force et il va falloir
encore réfléchir ça m'a presque jamais
arrivé en fait de gagner comme ça à la
maison
que peut-être si je me rappelle que
peut-être trois fois dans ma vie de
gagner presqu'entièrement à la maison
dizy calcul va super vite en lice alors
il doit avoir toutes les possibilités
ouais mais en fait le truc c'est qu'au
bout d'un moment c'est un peu comme un
disque dur en fait le cerveau c'est
comme un disque dur ssd à force de
l'utiliser et commence à y avoir des
choses qui mettent plus vraiment au bon
endroit est temps que tu peux pas
défragmenter le
le disque
bah il ya des bugs qui se rajoutent et
même si tu calcules vite je commence à
voir des fantômes à avoir des
hallucinations et ça marche plus aussi
bien qu'au début alors après comme je l
ai dit tout à l'heure hikaru il est
vraiment impressionnant pour ça parce
qu'il réussit à maintenir son niveau
pendant très longtemps mais bon il a
joué six heures et demie hier 20 bout
d'un moment même lui il va commencer à
avoir des problèmes même intel mais sait
aussi que
donc pas mal de tam depuis van cau 19
coups c'est pas contre firoud qu'il joue
il joue encore au pack internet roman et
ça complique pas mal de choses moi je
pense que ce que le vise maintenant qui
vient je pense qu'il vit ce qu'on va
laisser deux rois des 1,27
dans de ces 3 2 dames à quatre roues
abordant peu quatre dames aux quatre
calais ou quatre faux bouge peu importe
où les boissons mieux mais tu sais très
bien ce que je veux dire oui mais
alireza y joue pam il joue pas mal les
finales où il est mieux oui encore ok
les points sont mis au pas ce que le
fougueux plus fort ici parce que le pion
à ceux qui ont passé tous les final doit
être assez désagréable - les noirs ont
de quoi se féliciter aussi quand même
parce que par exemple l'homme à la casse
de 5 pour le cavalier ok elle est
souvent je suppose même s'ils purent se
virer d'être désagréable ils sont peut
pas l'éviter ou est simple c'est fort
c'est fort c'est
peut-être d'ailleurs b3 plutôt qu aux
enjeux seront
possibles ou quelque part est qualifié
c'est pour ça qu'ils viennent que
peut-être moins pour faire 4 pour ne pas
perdre ce tempo plus tard il a foncé en
direct et après tu veux alors il ya 3 ou
4 h cadre et ce sera le début d' enfant
avant si tu réussis à moi tes rêves 3h
et 4h cadrage 5
sam que le noir trouvent du conteur joue
ça peut trouver moins cher j'aime quand
tu disais 4
[Rires]
non mais oui c'est désagréable moi
j'aurais pris les blancs tous les jours
et j'aurais pensé la gagne en fait ouais
mais cheyrou doit bien connaître cette
finale du coup au bas salat elle se joue
tout seul en fait elles 3g 4 h 5 c'est
bon dos tout remanier arabe il peut
espérer que se sauver il peut pas
espérer de icare ton aigre
non il ne peut pas y cartonné
énoncés c'est quand même une belle
finale
après le manque de temps sera pas trop
préjudiciable
dans cette finale est encore comme ça il
va enchaîner prendre tout comme un deux
trois quatre cinq
quand même donc c'est beaucoup mais il
est mou mais il est moins bien et
alireza donc ce genre de final il est
pas mal quand même
je pense que bientôt
tout cas ils hésitent à rentrer dedans
est-ce que les couleurs de son pays
envisage de changer les règles sans
logis
je crois pas
regarde il est content là
1h51 contre 38 minutes ça n'arrive pas
si souvent que ça les gars quand même
elle sait très bien qui calculait mais
est ce que c'est bien sauf à de tels
faits ne le
sait pas forcément son gros point fort
non plus hein même si s'accroche bien
parce que c'est une finale plutôt
stratégique est plutôt de placement que
de cale snd fois ci
le fou en b2 avec un pion pas ch en
finale c'est très fort comme un fouet f3
avec un pion passées à tes la partie
fischer timan nom qui est très connue ne
pas tim and time and of pardon avec un
fouet f3 est un pion passé à comme ça
oui our time and as fait
tu aimes bien les livres de timan
gelé en fait j'ai lu quelques extraits
et les extraits à noter l'excellent mais
on m'a dit j'aimerais juste
je trouve que c'est un très bon
écrivain échiquéen ghanty man
petits camarades réveille toi comment
dix camarades
ça pourrait être le joueur soviétique y
camarades
nakamura
ça pourrait être un nom rusnak amour of
tavaris nakamura
ça donne combien les turbines pour le
monde 0-0 mais
là c'est plus
000 sites en deux sets
mais c'est hyper flippant de face à
celui qui est pire flippante donc je
pense pas qu'il va lever ils voient ils
vont
ils a2 d'anniversaire pour fille ruth ja
on pourra l'appeler comme ça les vidéos
siegen
ferroudja contre iccat de nakamura
nul entre mazet cornette pas la peine de
regarder la partie je croise
ici carpediem y sont ballaigues de son
temps
il ya quelques personnes assez créatifs
dans le tchat
cherche à sauver les meubles way i
castorama ils vont tellement loin en
fait c'est trop les amis
en tout cas la partie assez intense
aujourd'hui même si les coûts n'arrive
pas c'est une position tellement
intéressante
bon bah c'est très intéressant de voir
cette finale en fait je suis
complètement sûr qu'on va voir sur
l'échiquier et méthodiquement c'est
intéressant pour moi comment les droits
devront se défendre
rien rien issue ils n'arrivent pas en
fait c'est trop dur pour lui à moins que
c'est bizarre que t'as pas su avoir un
incident à l'haïtien
en fait un grammy qu
on m a sorti une nouvelle nation une
position avec un léger avantage gagnant
léger avantage gagnant
ça veut dire que quiconque est un peu
mieux mais tu sais très bien qu est ce
que tu va offrir pendant les prendre car
un proche un coup très dur en france
demeure d'offrir 3 et donc à chaque fois
l'adversaire doit de le contrer de
manière ou l'autre et donc ça ils
apprennent davantage gagnant parce qu à
babré sûr que l'adversaire va pas le
faire tout un terrain national qui va
voir justement s'équipe de
parce qu'en fait de tenir alireza il
peut la connaître en plus possible le
sait parce qu'il y avait tellement bien
préparé aujourd'hui
pour la peine aujourd'hui le hic à
roanne assez bien ali reza
j'ai pas envie de partir là d'aller voir
les autres échiquiers parce que je sais
qu'il va jouer rapidement hikaru et j'ai
envie de voir le coup je suis trop
curieux bien sûr je vois je verrai plein
- es que 38 9% mais là il peut plus en
fait
10 minutes maximum encore pour ce coup
20h55 ouaip le dos et le vois je
l'accueille
mais monde d'un autre côté on pensait
qu'il rentrerait dans ce truc là et
qu'il restera encore une heure on
pensait pas qu'il allait autant se
met pas ce que c'est que là que j'ai
compris les dangers
je ne sais pas qu'est-ce qu'il vous
pourrez peut-être tu sais il est repris
roidot lieu de
après tant que cette fois ci ce que
laissait d'horreur de davos a le droit
je ne
vois pas 12,8 éléphants
oui puisqu'on ne plus employer oui en
plein de coups et y'a que tous réfutent
qui égalisait et encore il faut aussi y
croire en fait même si tu le vois
je pense que ce mois là
en fait pour l'instant paraît qu
il voit pas de position qui leur
convient ça me fait penser à ces
carreaux cole pepsico phrase que j'avais
lu il a cru le voir pour le croire mais
il faut aussi le croire pour le voir et
ça c'est un peu ça résume un peu ce tour
f8 en fait
c'est qu'est le problème il est double
oui l'expression de sa gueule ce gène
appelé à qu'est ce que c'est nul de
thermo ans maintenant
il se tient la tête cabeza
il y un peu le chat de temps en temps
ça c'est pas moi et cardiogramme folie
il y en a des jolis seins
pièce demain 2 - oui mais il va la
récupérer un
caramel bonbons de chocolat
depuis le moment où je t'ai dit trois
minutes c'est 10 minutes ça fait déjà 2
30 glad
ça veut dire qui tresse de 30 et je
gagne ce qui peut que ouais ça c'est ma
gueule préfet réussir est
tu penses il aurait pu être un bon
acteur hikaru un genre de jim carrey
écoute
c'est la même question sur kasparov ils
sont très bien comme les acteurs mais
toute la vie et je joue qu'un seul rôle
ou et le na waie qu'un seul rôle
il n'y a que 50 % de chances pour qu'on
soit encore dans la prépa d'alireza
graphiquement plutôt si pas objective
fourni tu sais que les américains en
fait je sais pourquoi il faut le mandat
exprès non même pas en fait ils
regardent toutes les parties en même
temps
et du coup en fait j'ai remarqué un truc
c'est que de prime abord quand tu vous
regarde l'extérieur tu as l'impression
que les parties longues sont très
longues et a le temps de regarder les
quatre en même temps et de comprendre
mais quand tu as fait ce taf de
commenter les parties en direct tu te
rends compte à un moment donné tu peux
regarder deux maximum en fait on voilà
voilà paris 10 heures 3 minutes 30 bat
mike d'âge aux pires dieu dix minutes
pour rien tu savais que tu vois le faire
noam et répétez pas cette approche où tu
sais tu vas faire ferez quoi
y'a quelqu'un qui crie naka il est
encore en prépare
[Rires]
les américains sur le stream 1 goutte et
chipper jones is still there frappe
syfia route et le tempo je suis mort non
mais il va jouer tempo la regarde il
connaît encore
et si un jour maintenir à eux deux joe
cole est de 4
et là on ne peut pas faire
roy de deux
je
crois d un quasi tempo non mais il a
encore un
live à jouer tempo regarde
hockey dame 17
on va penser de tempo
on va avoir si il a analysé les finales
résultante au point on voit le savoir
comme après que voler ou 4s que le voit
bouger son fouquet coupe à fitou et la
mort après damas café
p3o possible mais oui
recife b3 vite
crois bien vite parce que ce sera un
choix pour être dans tous les cas il
devra choisir la case pour son fou vue
de faire et savoir beaucoup montré
là ça va être à peu près équivalent moi
j'aurais joué deux des trois plus tôt je
comprends je te comprends ok déjà pour
ne pas rogner nouveau et puis quoi est
ce que léopold opur surcoût de voix m
aubry est en plus fou c'est un fou des
deux os il ya trop de raisons pour avoir
envie de p3 s'ils jouent tempo encore là
c'est qui c'est parce que sinon tu
prends quand même quelques minutes trois
mois
ok mais c'est moi ça veut dire pas qui
oppose 3-1 ap ap le faut
dire qui c'est je pense quand même
parce que c'est un choix important quand
même
la grosse turbine elle dit quoi
la grosse turbine
c'est le coup la même qualité mais
plutôt aux banques ce qui sait
il a joué très vite et c'est quand même
un choix est maintenant vital alors
après d'amateurs d'invocateur faut
coller aux 4 ou aller avec le foot pour
moi c'est très très dur comme le que six
joutes mpc qui sait sauf une
seule chose est claire après que le cad
il va pas jouer au foot 4 parce que
kovalev dodo fourchette on va le voir à
l'écran on va le voir arriver on va
l'essayer carouge est étonnant qu'ils
réfléchissent ici un jour américain
d'ailleurs on t'offre un
ouais ouais
ouais donc comme souvent aux échecs
mattern après 24 coup on voit arriver
forcément dans une finale où il ya très
peu de pièces de terre
finale qui est sur moi me
bricoler ou kadhafou f4 nettement la
première ligne si je vous fais quatre
thèmes poussée qui connaît
nettement
si vous me demandez les raisons pour
jour ce pas
il est encore dans la préparer les
accords de réfléchir
quand le fichier d'enfoirés quand même
non mais là c'est quand même quelque
chose non à la tht est encore dans le
fichier est 10e la ville est encore dans
le fichier
peut-être à la fin de la partie il va
juste ça mon cher et si tu es resté à
notre cou et puis partir en cours lee
kai est bien rempli
mais il criait ça doit être vraiment
désespérant pour icare au regard il est
dégoûté
il est juste dégoûté et moi je suis
content parce que j'aime bien quand les
gens sont punis pour cette approche est
normal
qu edf 6
pas sûr qu'il le fallait se dépêcher
parce qu'en fait tu as peut-être envie
que le pion aille en f3 pour toucher la
case de trois patios poids / coller 6 à
moi c'est clair qu'ils ont
tissés entre coucou aux solides pour
pisser n'ont même pas et les retourner
tout de suite où ils puissent aussi
rapide que ça
non je pense pas qu'ils puissent eux
aussi rapide que toi et c'est le walo ah
bon parce qu'il est nerveux ouais
il va empêcher g4 oui mais on peut faire
j'ai quand même ici
d'ailleurs
qu'est ce que moi je ferai ici
c'est la première ligne de l'ordi mais
ça aurait été mon réflexe aussi
d'autres manières c'est mon coup le plus
sûr est obligé de jeu h4 à un moment
donné tu es obligé obligé donc pourquoi
pas faire maintenant parce que tout
autre moyen tu vois le faire qu'est la
seule question se serait ce que je fais
trop d 1 ha non je pense que c'est
pour empêcher tour des 8 mai moi par
contre 3,7 au 184 tour des
8,3 ces deux tours des quatre je
regarderai ça mais j'ai joué cinq qui a
peut-être peut-être juste version il n'a
pas achevé 3 parce que au lieu 2
à non
pas trop peut-être n'a pas voulu faire
parce que tous ces cas très complet les
noirs veulent
non mais je peux dire je te fais une
confidence il savait en fait juste non
je sais de comprendre la logique de le
charger
oui juste si tu peux montrer après
au web 3.0 faut recadrer peut-être avant
deux tours suite avec les dc4
c'est plutôt ça comme quoi
le problème peut-être
mettant des huit sujets sans croix g7
après ça on peut le pathos ou de
sécateurs tour solide
ossature solide
mais il a su juste tu vois la ligne mais
on leur dit ça reste quand même pour le
moment h41
droit ces deux équivalents mais h4 c'est
quand même tu es vraiment sûr h4 donc
disons qu ayant cours en cuc et au
passif qui tue les faux pas mais parfois
aussi le de refaire ou chaussettes et
obligés de nous arrêter parce qu'ils
sont tous réjouis
donc roissy d'où tu pues veut pas le
temps manque et h4 prochain je pense que
c'est même chose
je regrette beaucoup de cette position
que les banques seront obligées à offrir
roy seul e et acheter leur est
questionnable tout le reste est
questionnable mais ces deux coups là tu
vas aller faire c'est sûr
j'espère qu'il va pas faire de dinguerie
alireza j'espère surtout tu vas pas
faire comme contre radjabov et de
prendre une heure là
non mais il faut continuer à garder le
flou là
je pense qu'il doit être tellement
excitée qu ils voient pas le faire dans
tous les cas
on voit des gens passaient des fois on
voit des gens des gens reflet dans la
glace un timbre à 20
j'essaye de voir des pit en fait
parce qu'on n'en voit pas trop avec
cette caméra c'est l'inconvénient du
coup j'essaye de les voir dans la télé
normalement il connaît cette finale non
mais icônes et jusque là il doit
connaître le plan dans la finale aussi
mais plus de coups précis maintenant
et c'est tellement comblé
les octrois dépit de premiers mots d'un
haut niveau duda numéro un et pau numéro
2 rajaona numéro 3
voilà ok il ya vingt quatrième
donc tu m'as dit que le canada n'a pas
trahi en a plus
une épaule numéro 1
ya match c'est juste parce qu'il a une
pizza au lieu de sa tête quoi
si tout se passe bien au niveau
technique
des amis aujourd'hui
il ne faut pas partir parce que c'est la
victoire ça sent la wind
ah bah oui une victoire contre nac a
quand même ça se prend
mon cher ami
ben ali reza il rejoindrait les gros
favoris du tournoi après ça va jouer
avec caruana évidemment avec les peaux
vise net avantage pour ding n'est pas
déjà fait nul ça c'était prévu
ancestrale avantage godding non la nuit
une donnée qu'on l'avait prévu nous hier
on s'était dit quand on sait quand on
avait discuté ensemble
que ça allait faire nul
dingen que les taux de plus comme tu
veux qu'on aille voir ou epos comme il
voit réfléchir qui malheureusement oui
je propose qu'on passe un petit
échiquier par contre
serait pas là ok s'arrêter après tour ce
faux-bond 5 tours 8 jusque là à ma vie à
mes amis souvent en football c'est comme
mon deuxième coup pour prendre sur ce
site mais souvent à fait faux bond sans
co2 un coup ko pour
provoquer les noirs à jouer à 6 et puis
a reculé avec le fou et b6 devient
faible
donc
c'est chouette un
mois pourquoi c'est chaud que ça ok je
vois ici non mais c'est mieux pour les
blancs mais je ne sais pas infinie oh
bien sûr ce n'est pas fini mais jeux du
match
3-6 enfin petit tour rapide juste déjà
pour comprendre ce qui se passe un peu
partout et on pourra s'arrêter quelque
part après ouais c'est juste pour se
donner une idée vlad ok ça
malheureusement donc
non heureusement et ils ont rentré dans
cette finale la pause que je sais que
sectionnelles dont ryan o'byrne mis ces
bonnes nouvelles on veut pas que fabiano
s'envole à tous ces points de ce point
de vue d'accords donc aller c'est connu
que cette finale dorian c'est connu
depuis j'ai pas beaucoup de neige et
donc moi aussi je ne les aime pas
longtemps parce que ce serait que c'est
rien du tout radjabov n'est pas je pense
qu'une zone réputée
vient de nulle connu
je me demande d'ailleurs s'il n'ont pas
s'ils n'ont pas
accord de sept nuls avant la partie le
plus probablement
confiée en tant que ex professionnel il
a joué h 4 assez vite en haut au
fir eis élevé ou et vous voilà ce qu'on
ne sait pas ce qu'il faut faire c'est
exactement ce qu'il faut faire et ferrer
deux parties il réalise la partie
parfaite 1 pour le moment faut pas le
laisser respirer il car où les gens nous
disent dans le chatt paix mais il a du
temps d'avant s'il faut l'utiliser mais
pourquoi l'utiliser il s'est levé non ce
n'était pas la bonne came pardon
pourquoi l'utiliser c'est l acam nul
mais peu importe sa hikaru de jouer
pourquoi utiliser du temps et pas mettre
plus de pression si tu sais que de toute
façon tu vas faire h4
ok je suppose l'autre va pas trop loin
des salles isaf et non plus où il va
faire l'un des cours
normal contre les 2,5
ici
il est vrai on peut jouer frustrant mais
l'amant il est vrai plus offert fou de
dos pour si jamais qui orne
le faut contrôler ce diagonale
si les noirs vont pousser les pions
normalement c'est plutôt fou des deux
parce que tour des huit tu le crains pas
tharwa ces deux on a de toute façon un
coup que tu veux jouer dans tous les cas
photo
wesdome est d'aller pointer chaque jeu 4
3 c'est comme ça que les pilotes doivent
être tu peux économiser f3 peut-être
même oui j'ai quatre ans parce que bien
sûr noté les forces
économie si tu peux et l'autre à lourdes
doit choisir
le sais tape comme on le voit motors est
bon surtout
c'est quoi la vente à juin la position
peut même pas un avantage humains là
c'est juste l'avantagent fatah un pion h
passé est un fou qui peut contrôler la
casse de promotion ça va pas plus loin
que ça c'est aussi con que ça est un
pion passé il en a pas
d'ailleurs je pense
que dans cette finale
c'est pas du tout grave si les taux sont
inchangés
moi je les gardiens ici ils voient
obtenir les pièces sur h 54 je pense que
c'est pas grave si les tours sont des
changes est ce que tu vas avoir oui
parce que je pense de les revoir vous
voie lactée mais bon par contre n'ont
maintenant les ai chargés c'est très dur
ici parce que lecavalier est de 5 brook
une seule colonne ouvert se fout des
deux valables ok aussi ouais
pourquoi pas avoir l'air fou des deux
directement à 18h ffu d2 direct c'était
pas très malin quoi tu serais prix
qu'elle prend des deux rois ces deux cas
valeo prend enfin
sa aurait pas été
superbe
c'est pour ça qu'il a préféré le mettre
en f4 probablement un peu plus fort que
donnait la tour et le fou quoi
assez subtil ouais
c'est subtil
or dilemme bien phu g5 aussi c'est
pâques ont fusé 5 en vrai
je pense que ça change rien du tout
parce que après fou de 2 je pense que
loi je f5
donc dans ces regards je pense que ça je
vais le faire f 6 il a fait food et de
direct j'aurais pu vous des 2 au 6 mai
fu g5
ça se joue vraiment à des détails
25 et sir 3 f4 très importants l'été par
exemple tour euros à 7 euros 4 tours
joués touchwiz ray classiques comme
défense ouais ouais les noirs doivent
voir le mur contre donc ce que je
racontais avant oui bien sûr et la
joueuse
est ce que tu peux faire g3 du coup
pour préparer le 3g 4
talent tombe pas
se forme
il ya des trucs comme 54e
aux 4
ouais ils pouvaient aussi qu'il y en ait
jeff j'ai collé 6 et 6,5 olofsson
a
progressé
moi je ne sais pas peut-être un peu je
joue john 3 heures ou à vii à son tour
achoui tour change
et puis tu veux aller sur quatre
parfois travailleurs tour à quatre
cavaliers 6 h 6 oui
4 3 points
et tu veux aller retour au 4 3
3 et 6
là je tour dans
voulu corriger 5 évidemment mais
maintenant surveiller g5 tu vas voir
tour des 7
6 3 7 6 sur moi est de toute manière je
veux aux sacrifiés l'un de mes pions là
pour casser notre structure poste ça
peut être devenir très dangereux c'est
hyper dangereux là nordine 0,27 moi je
pensais que
pas sûr qu ils réagiront pas sûr
rachdi en fait j'ai trois quarts et 2004
oui je comprends le turbo cette tour jo
tourbus hissé à 4 très vite il faut ce
passionnant
c'est loin d'être sûr hyper compliqué
oui
un calcul de l'idh est allé au bout
d'une logique enfin il ya des coups
candidat logique mais c'est pas
forcément les meilleurs il a fait j'ai 3
[Musique]
pourquoi pas mouais moi je réfère plutôt
ce que je veux dire bref pour moi ou
au kehrweg cette chaussure pause
mais tu veux juste jouer tranquille
parce qu'avec les noirs tapé juste pas
de coups et il fait h 50 il veut si je
de coûts je pense que les noirs vue à le
jouer cinq cadres peut-être pas tout de
suite mal de noir bulls h pause
peut-être d'ailleurs tout de suite mais
au sens qu'avec les deux cadres
pourquoi pas d'ailleurs gagné de
l'explosion il ya peut-être maintenir
emphatique
et principal
pascal
furon major prouvées en cour mois que
la ferraille 7
mais si je fais juste haut-rhin ici
pour 8 tu veux dire
il me fait peur à lire et zalla
je me demande s'il est apte de tasque
ce que tu penses qu'il est apte ou de
tasque ou pas
normalement non
mais
n'empêche les finales est très agréable
mais ici il faudrait être vraiment
francs comme
il peut le perdre non même pas comment
pas
peut-être juste pas gagnante
non moquer il n'a pas voulu se dépêcher
avec h5 d'accord donc offert un peu du
forcing que joue à l'heure cette finale
comme jour national aux angoisses de
les voir déjà ce que l'autre fait
puis peut-être même f3 tour joué tout
rejoindre et que les 2 et 4 mais julie
finale d'habitude oui bien sur mac en
bio il améliore son droit quoique
l'essai de criaient deux pions pas ses
enfants qu'elle voit ce que son
adversaire
royal c'est pas la peine de regarder
cette position n'est
se faire passer pour
machines la lpm quoi parce que tu crois
pas tout cas que les tu peux pas en fait
ouais
normalement ces rois ces deux là où le
plus évident
normalement
là il prend son temps il avait pris son
temps après j'ai 3 on m'a conduit
chez
vous obtenez un tel final avec les noirs
contre personne vous êtes vous
content car ça vous finirez toutefois il
n'est pas gagné
mais est-ce que marrant c'est que telle
qu'on n'a qu'à par exemple il a joué
sais pas combien de centaines de parties
où les deux parties à cadence
différentes occasions mais n'a jamais
appris schiro matthew freud
ya cru qui est capable de gagner de tel
jeunes alj pas où ils se disent c'est
pas neuf sur dix
rounds sur tout 2009
sa calcul du rhin côté
ko aussi
oui messieurs et kerry s'est pris à
préparer et bien ça est donc entrée de
gamme et le rythme des coups et ré me
fait part une nouvelle fois
j'ai remis pour l'instant on tombe en
furent les mêmes situations cuillère en
quelque sorte de 106 qu'avant-hier même
pas le sens qu
il faut un coup et puis il se met à
réfléchir et 1 comprend pas trop ce que
ça
donne l'impression qu'il va jouer là
quand même
[Musique]
on va voir
on va voir ses biens avec l'expression
dans des spectateurs pris part au cost
oui c'est bien ça et les stations pour
le terme c'est bien ça prépare
l'holocauste
parce que vous risquez rien
96 tu peux pas pour faire f3 et en fait
on était matrix est partout revient on
peut jouer aussi fou j'ai cinq
noms f3 je pense que c'est aussi
beaucoup que horwath 2 si tu vas presque
5 kg 4
les taux
alors rejoint il adore ressemble à ce
que le fou il est bloquée à pau ce qui
dope le cours parce que en gros tu
bouges plus au furet
non je crois je pense que tout au fond
de moi avec les dates hors jeu autour
juin
moi je refais la brosse 2
avant
va pas la gagner
ou pour le moins bon
en fait maintenant les échecs moderne si
t'es pas très bons en finale j'étais
juste fermé en fait
parce qu'ils vont toujours retrouver une
finale un peu inférieur ils vont
toujours seul à défendre je sais pas
mais j'ai l'impression que chaque fois
ses roues quand ils le voient un final
et le regard sur cette finale comme
s'ils gagnent de la naissance regard sur
un port burger quoi j'ai cette
impression
ni avec les cimes fois ci il n'y avait
que peu trop de coupeau
ff iii
sidya des burgers vegan
attend surtout g8 ya pas g4 direct
en fait
ici collective
j'ai page 5 là c'était mon plan
la joue moi aussi
j'ai préparé
j'avais ma petite saloperie tour
évoqué mais ça aurait pu
parce qu'en fait même ça c'est pas
clairement
je vois pas comment tu mets un mode puni
pour double
mécanique mois
d'art chinois pour obliger jouer collège
chez eux
je peux que leucate au collet de ça
mais bon j'ai quatre directe possible
sur tours g8 en fait
a dit quoique à des fils ici je fais ça
je pense qu'en tant
cantat plus vraiment contrôle sur ce
sens que je pense que tu perds une
grosse partie des gens voulaient ça je
pense que je fais un coup quoi
si je vais pas réfléchir je connaissais
pas je reviens
quatre antennes comme carl scène pour
continuer à presser ça
en gros je pense que la future h suite
ok et est ce qu'il veut avec quatre
peut-être le vrai trailer trash rachat
ouais ouais obligatoire
un comme ça après 18
hockey
et
georges tron
et voilà et en ces moments réussis et
leur féroce de leur pivot juste voie de
3 way we n'a pas fait rose
à
bergen quoi
mais du coup si on remontait ce que
l'erreur finalement
c'était pas la
preuve en fait j 4 quand il pouvait
[Musique]
mais bon il y aurait d'autres problèmes
en jeu 4 doit pas être une faute qu'il
met par contre dans tous les scénarios
tels a besoin de nos papilles voici
quand même
les bleus quoi
c'est marrant
mais je
ne gagne pas de définir parce que le roi
ne pas aimer je sais je sais pas si dans
en fait si le coup réflexe de tout le
monde on a bien montré la variante où on
avait vraiment besoin d'eau du gua sur
sedo pour qu'ils puissent se déplacer
sur trois
qui la fout g5 ici aussi
oui oui
je joue briller le couple
et là maintenant il ya f4 et une
nouvelle fois il avait eu un tendre de
plus avec le roi il aurait eu droit en
d3 et
c'est triste
c'est triste venise
ouais c'est relou
des tâches 5 aussi était un plomb comme
danny
williams a pas ce cas
à 5 au moins ça a été lié lié à l'idée
d'augmenter la tour sur 4 pour les
activer tant que l'accord était de
fermer ce que lâche sur chaque ligne
conneries garde chez à chaque fois
l'ailé la tour est
obligé de se déplacer sur les premières
quelque part est toujours pas de lignes
ouvertes dans ces cas là alors qu'on n'y
a pas de lignes ouvertes alors c'est
sale et des deux groupes
le groupe de la tourbe
race est chiant
je pense qu'il va la tenir sans problème
en fait c'est comme dans tous les cas
aujourd'hui ce soir quelqu'un de votre
bien entouré par vladimir quand même
pourquoi quand même qu'on les prépare
non mais comment tu veux qu'ils gagnent
en fait s'il n'arrive pas à presser même
ça
comment il peut gagner juste une partie
en fait
si l'autre essaye pas si l'autre et ça
n'est pas assez important ce que pour
elle c'est qu'aujourd'hui il avait quand
même une position dans - tu veux devenir
le roi ci ne se pas consumé
ouais parce que le problème c'est que
c'est pour ça qu'il réussit à battre les
joueurs à 26 50 27 parce que contre eux
il aurait fait 100% avec cette prépa
mais contre les joueurs du tap tap tap
tap tap il manque quelque chose
c'est bien ça ce que je voulais dire
qu'ils commandent cooking
bon il peut il a encore un tout petit
peu de jeu il peut encore espérer mais
c'est vrai que ça manque de précision
après il est jeune encore un il a le
temps mais
fait sireix est ce problème là il est
tout de suite
là où qua non est le truc en fait ce que
tu peux pas régler ce problème avec les
moyennes d'entraînement que d'employer
avant toute ta vie non là ça veut dire
analyser les ouvertures avec leur dit et
de ce qu'on t'en ai joué sur se jouer en
ligne ou les deux peut pas être
appliquée ici les finales non tu peux
pas travailler comme ça toute ta vie tu
vas rester pas bien la différence du
coût du
non c'est clair à chaque fois alors
quand tu vois je un truc qui voit que le
chocquois
ça va toujours été
pro
a c'est tellement dur fait tellement
précis en fait contre ces joueurs là bah
oui c'est très difficile ces quatre au
mes l'autre
c'est un enfant des tournois a mis aussi
à
aa
g4
mais bon gagner encore un en gros ce que
vaut aujourd'hui c'est vrai ce qui a
l'air bag moderne quoi
allait avoir deux premiers siècles quoi
mais ces quatre c'est quand même
particulier comme tout au sm ça expose
bien dans les cases doit
en fait juste un coup comme le 5 pour
avoir sur g 4 4
pas exactement ici parce qu'il a pu en
prendre quatre mais oui là c'est ffkm et
même réussissant fait loi et sur h5 du
coup maintenant
ce que quatre ça passe
oui aucun problème 4 non non tu pourrais
faire grève si le souci parce que les
pions sont bloqués monde oui oui oui
c'est tout à l'heure mais en gros il
fallait aller bloquer quand même j'ai 4
mais là il va le faire alireza chez 4
quand même
et sur f4 maintenant claudio haut autour
eux en août ont eu envie parce que a pas
de calais 3
h 24 ouais comme les jeux d'eau tout aux
quatre tours 4 il ya des trucs en herbe
comme ces cas de troubles après tu veux
pas tomber en fait
je sais pas parce que je veux toujours
bien sûr qu'avec le temps je t'attendais
ans dont je comprends tout à fait mais
moi je voulais souligner
huawei ouais ouais ouais vous savez il
ya une salle technique même quand
quelqu'un vous a fait ses cadres photos
d'hommes et trop à doubler les casses de
gagner et vous regardez ses salles oui à
double creux de 4
non j salaire perçu et perspectives
quand même
non peut-être qu'on a une chance qu'un
droit c'est 2 s'il ya des problèmes
peut-être avec la case detroyat f4
peut-être un il va pas de fouet
[Musique]
dont par contre on comment dire un tant
que joueur
très dynamique ils voient les trous qui
s'ouvre bah oui
peut-être on voulait troquer cette
affaire et il voit donc un truc
s'affaiblit il voyait aller quoi
mais surgit 4 il veut quand il veut
peut-être 3g 6 mais du coup on va faire
tout à tout va ou
non dans ces cas-là au fuseau cinq jours
génial oui parce que ça montre la
colonne des roues et les jours génial
parce que ça a libéré la tour et
d'ailleurs il est vrai pour cette
scénario là car le pylône sur secrète il
a vraiment pas besoin de roissy doivent
me regarde là comme c'est ça devient dur
quoi tu vas devoir faire commence déjà
menacées partout dont j ai fait une
grosse même qu'il peut faire j'ai six
tours eu un roi 9 7% que c'est pour
illustrer
jallet gff d'euros
soit avait pu gagner tout de suite du
kent impôts
non mais j'ai quatre là c'est fait avec
g3 et f3 pour g4 si tu fais pas
maintenant
que tu as there be come back à et et
surgit quatre cavaliers f6 déjà sa
menace rien mais jugé f prises et 12 ans
parce qu elle est rousse sur le trou sur
re5 surtout et c'est heureux oui
toujours se passe je suppose tour bouffe
aux cavaliers bovero à ses deux héros
assez d'eau et les trous ouais ouais il
peut plus faire c'est 5 enfin il peut
plus stand en fait qu'on puisse en
croatie 3 à 5 fu de weeds pour le
spectateur
à ça il faut deux ou trois cadres
finito
mais bon il me fait flipper en fait un
bon duo de coachs pour
moi il me fait peur
en fait il fait très peur anyresa
il prend son concert monde qui connaît
ses faiblesses en finale mais ça montre
rien du tout avant d'arrêter de vous
inventer des vies ça montre juste qu'il
sait pas en fait pas qui connaît ses
faiblesses et justice et pas il obligé
de réfléchir
alors que l'open des bois maintenant en
jouant g4 puis tour d éventuellement au
tour avec l'idée de les mettre sur cinq
forcer les noirs de prendre sur jkd
bouffer sur le j4
éventuellement
d'une émission d'une expression juste
douche pour une tension madoff compte et
éventuellement pas mal d'échangés les
tours un moment donné parce que les
noirs peuvent pas tolérer d'offres
plaisent sur les deux extrémités de
l'échiquier alors les pions de l'edough
qui ont passé d'un côté et les voies
lactées sur l'autre c'est ça les
techniques normal de gagner ça
arrive et c'est sur la fête il a tout
fait pour
il a tout misé dessus
après c'est pas gagné encore
aussi pourquoi est-ce-que e5 a été mieux
que ce qu'attend
souvent quand votre adversaire contrôler
les cases de son fou ici les cases
noires vous devrez noircir votre
position conquois vous savez il ya ces
techniques donc ce coup là leur dos
mettre le club sur 2,5 c'est très dur à
expliquer
parce que des fois c'est le cas des fois
celle inverse
- souvent ce bien le cas alors un dom
pour que son fouet à sa fin et les
autres pièces contrôle moines des cases
où ils sont bon quoi c'est que souvent
c'est bien dans les positions ou des
mieux nantis bat souvent c'est bien
moins bien quoi ça dépend surtout si ça
peut se faire toucher par derrière en
vrai
d'autres manières le cac volley sur 2,5
fois qu'on est il n'est pas aussi faible
coût comme le roi et succède tu peux te
permettre de jeu 5 parce que surdoué a
pas toujours réussi mais en fait c'est
concret ya pas de n'y a pas de règne en
fait
5 c'est bien aussi pour créer du contour
je sais mais c'est juste c'est parce que
bon quand les points où l'impôt à
couvert tu peux pas juste rester là mais
je sais déjà c'est un peu comme dit
maxime c'est bien parce que c'est bien
en fait enfin deux raisons bon ici les
raisons complètement
mais c'est du calcul en fait c'est bien
parce ça marche parce que ça marche ou
de calculs oui menace la maison c'est là
ma région et
à mesure que tu mets le roi sur une
autre case un truc tu changes un truc
d'une case et s'arrête tout changer
justement sur ce twitt ça marche pas
droit à porter mais je sais mais ça
marche parce que ça marche c'est comme
ça
si ça marche douce que ça marche dans ce
qu'elle va jamais à prendre de jouer les
finales
parce que concrètement elle n'arrive pas
il doit voir les trucs pour s'orienter
et les calculs et jusqu'au bout les
riffs points et c'est le troisième
portier des filets quoi
regardons et là c'est pas son
nom je comprends moins comme en iran
pour cette génération en général de
joueurs en ligne doivent avoir des trucs
pour s'orienter
mais je pense plutôt rien parce que ton
connais beaucoup regard maxime par
exemple il joue assez bien les finales
globalement ok mais le problème chez
dior
louis par exemple
vire où il va pas se mettre aux livres
c'est impossible juste impossible il va
pas lire tous les livres qu'ils ont à
lui s'il va pas le faire les générations
différentes et très occupés concret
donc par contre il doit passer par cette
étape à mai inclus en faisant beaucoup
de finale qui sera en fête bat dans ce
collège va jamais devenir champion du
monde
je préviens moi je dois perdre tout son
temps pour apprendre les finales
de la manière d'oublier le monde
non nous
devons faire et il doit juste analyser
ou en périphérie empirique ou empiriques
moi oui et brad ziegler oui oui il voit
pire dans les milieux semiose année quoi
bien que comme ça il n'y a pas d'autre
méthode
les livrer comme ça pendant un an sans
arrêt jouer parfois mais surtout bossé
mais c'est ce que je te dis apidra leur
niveau il ya plus de règles c'est juste
ça va parce que ça va ça va pas parce
qu'il ya un gap comme ça dans son
éducation
est pareil que son gourou de l'époque
donc dans ce cas l'offre
mais pas d'epo paraît peut-être qu'il
n'est pas doué aussi pour les finales
c'est un jeu un peu différent non non
non dans son cas c'est tellement mauvais
que
[Musique]
vraiment moi
non mais j'ai quatre là c'est quand même
trop logique
après pu commencer par tour eux aussi
peut-être maintenant pour empêcher 5
mètres façon j'ai quatre empêche 5 c'est
vraiment trop logique g4 par contre j'ai
pas compris car ou du coup pourquoi il a
fait tout rage suite
au contrat au compteur ce cadre oui en
fait s'il le fait il le lingot d'or je
crains surtout
il l'a fait g4 ça va non bon ça peut
malgré tout ce que je dis
quand même si c'est une finale compliqué
je pense que c'est une telle il reste à
l'auteur vente une minute deux minutes
et cédric ou quoi quoique bien sûr tant
qu
il récupère du temps c'est pour ça que
c'était pénible
oui
peut-être là c'est quoi le plomb
m'annoncer tourache en fout c'est un
dans l'idéal non je pense tour d'eure
nos deux heures entre 5 letourneur s'il
empêche il peut pas empêcher commande
directe il peut pas vraiment heureux 5
voici offrir tout ce que tu veux je veux
faire ce double il va faire b5 ça de
façon c'est sûr ok je veux pas réfléchir
voilà où puis je pense peut-être pas de
différence parce que peut être les deux
forces
on est obligé de faire ça ça
c'est archi content dire que je suis
contente de ne rien dire j'ai deux puits
reliés et elle m'a pas forcé de
l'âge plus recommencer de jouer
tranquille quoi
j'allais vraiment gagnant pour les
blancs ça je pense que
ça les gagnants
là je peux m'occuper de mon papier
ou peut-être enfants
vont pas de raison pourquoi donner pas
m'occuper de mon papier
non là ça a l'air gagnant
est ce que tu peux faire un truc comme
tour g1 est fou c'est un dans un truc
pareil plus tard pour acheter que j'ai
cinq à pouvoir l'empêcher ou peut-être
mais je pense que j'aurai besoin de tout
le monde roy et sur milazzo cap des
compteurs joue un truc comme ça très
direct je veux juste que leur vie dit
que ça gagne pas parce que
patricia maléfices et si tu commences
par g5 envoi je suis rage ici c'est ok
donc c'est pas si simple en fait voir de
toutes façons il a fait b 5 1 pour
plusieurs
raisons tout droit pour contrer le
contre jour
mais d'abord et livrés il faut une force
de bouffer carreau est-ce que c'est pas
plus mal an de faire tourner un tu
menaces gf et suroît j-6 tourer
nos tours danse un très bon coup
tout à fait
mais tout revient il va faire être
viable j'ai quand même en fait
ça va revenir plus ou moins même en
réalité
complexe finale
bon le temps ça va pas être ça va pas
être une question en fait y'a trop de
coups plus ou moins facile je pensais
que neuf quoi jouer c'est pas assez pour
poser des problèmes sur les 20 minutes
peut-être la fatigue peut rentrer en
ligne de compte par contre pour icare ou
parce que très probable et moi ça sera
une autre journée marathonien
ça devrait durer longtemps
ça dépend d'alireza en fait si tank
beaucoup de temps ou pas mais ici
alireza y commence à prendre une heure
là pour jouer les dix prochains coups
savard durée de 6 heures
ils jouent tous les jours longtemps
alireza
dans les autres partis juste pour jeter
un oeil rapide
car ouanaya air
et ding c'est chaud ça avantage blanc il
va à cal de plus mais mais rien n'est
fait
mais ali reza il joue vraiment vraiment
beaucoup
il joue vraiment très longtemps
tous les jours au charbon
est née peau comme
comme dans les candidats qu'il avait
gagné des qui peut passer une journée
facile et rapide il le fait il a fait
une petite nul aujourd'hui ans
en une heure il récupère il conserve son
énergie est ici bleus vraiment c'est
parti
s'il joue longtemps c'est qu'il est
confiant en finale non c'est qu'il est
mieux après confiant
dans une opération présent voulais qu'il
fasse partie où il presse la voix là
ouais ça c'est vrai mais là il a quand
même une belle occasion il en aura pas
énormément des occasions comme ça dans
les candidats et s'il faut marquer plus
3 ou plus 4
ce serait quand même bien la concrétiser
on peut pas se contenter la dune nul
après les résultats des autres joueurs
en tête sont assez rassurant caruana qui
va pas faire le break n'est pas non plus
donc ils vont tous les deux être à
portée de fusil
ra abbas nepos nuls signé ouais
ça risque de durer six heures
[Musique]
au moins cinq je pense
enfin ça dépend vraiment de du temps de
réflexion d'aller réserve en réalité
donc il doit hésiter entre tour d un
pour menacer gf et tours 20 pour amener
la tour ont eu 5
entre l'un et l'autre
demain soir post si j'ai donc ça qu'ils
prennent du temps passé pas gênant du
tout non dis juste que né peau il gère
son tournoi en
en conservant son énergie en disant que
le tournoi est très long
comme il l'avait fait il ya il ya
l'année dernière mais
après ça
il fait ça aussi peut-être parce qu'il a
une moins bonne condition physique où
j'en sais rien moi c'est une stratégie
et puis aussi parce qu'il peut le faire
il est tombé sur radjabov avec les
blancs qui voulait faire annuler ils ont
quasiment pas joué c'est bien tombé pour
lui alireza là il va pas spécialement se
dire je vais vraiment faire une partie
courte et laisser un demi point pour
être bien en forme à la ronde 12 bien
sûr que non mais c'est des choses à
prendre en compte
carbo a joué très longtemps il hier
aussi hein c'est pas sûr qu'il ait assez
de de carburant dans le moteur
c'est plutôt radja qui rentre dans une
une annulaire non bah si tu compare avec
ce café alireza la première ronde mais
bon il faudrait encore pouvoir comparer
les parties alireza il aurait pu faire
une rapide contre
radjabov mais il a décidé de jouer à
fond
et là n'est pas l'abus jouer une partie
tranquille n'a pas essayé de forcer quoi
que ce soit
mais
voilà c'est un coût important
parce que c'est pas évident il peut pas
prendre en premier réellement parce que
surprise tour d un leroy va pouvoir
venir en russie ce et colmatée d'où
l'idée de commencer avec tours d un way
et on devrait ainsi prendre fg objet ce
serait dur d'authie cabriolé cette
position pour l'avoir cambriolé
cambrai
les deux marches ouais après il y aura
les deux pions pas ses alliés
mais après ça dépend vraiment c'est une
question de goût tournant autour des 1
sa change peut-être même rien puisque la
tour reviendrait plus tard vers f1 au g1
peut-être qu'en réalité ce les deux
coups sont exactement pareil parce que
peut-être que sur les deux coups il doit
jouer avec gm j'ai et que la tour
qu'elle soit en d1 ou en saas sa chance
est réellement rien le pire en fait
c'est que
même quand on adoption pas cgh moins
qu'andré nous avons échangé les pions
sur l'île d'ô d'un petit ne se voit pas
et des gens là c'est parce que les
problèmes sont les mêmes les pions pub
ce domaine
hoyau haïssent ils échangent tous les
pions il pourra peut-être un couvreur
moyenne deux
sacs et les locaux à lille
mais toi même comme ça avec les blonds
c'est pas si facile de pousser les pions
à quatre peut-être
même ça c'est pas alors que visuellement
tu as l'impression que tu es quand même
quasi gagnant avec les blancs
et en vérité c'est pas simple
quoique peu trop
aux pieds d'or d'abord après toi
et tu montres leroy
quoique ok moi perso j'aime pas
permettre de tels peillon comme tu le
contrôle bien quand même
tordères
il a l'air confiant en tout cas il s'est
levé d'un pas déterminé
le tour demain autour des 4 4 c'est une
idée même pas vraiment
toute façon il est obligé de prendre
quasiment ce que sur wager six tours 1
et du coup c'est débile tueur mêleront
f77 a perdu un temps moi non plus et
afyon premier tour 5 mais c'est juste
pour
imager
en quart ou lui de toute façon il n'a
pas l'embarras du temps
il doit prendre une décision il doit
jouer encore huit coups il a 19 minutes
il va pas traîner un il va prendre
angers 4 d'ailleurs étonnant qu ali reza
soient levés mais bon après des fois ça
permet de faire circuler le sang aussi
d'irriguer le cerveau
parce que je pense que son coût c'est
vraiment un objet ou alors peut-être qui
s'est levé pour dire mais je n'ai pas
vraiment dérangeant du coup je peux
partir c'est pas un gros caillou fouet
volontiers oui mais n'a pas trop le
choix en fait
principalement parce que tu ouvres les
colonnes f pour le tour et je suis perçu
avec le change des tours wes avantageux
pour les blancs ça c'est sûr mais il a
peut-être pas le choix on fait aussi
aussi un jour du libre la casco quatre
doubles pour le pop et blanc bien sûr
non mais c'est sûr mais c'est juste
qu'en fait ce truc c'est qu'il ose
couceiro a g6 mai à tours 1 pour la toux
reçu ouais donc au bout d'un moment et
comme je le disais un tourin tu dois
revenir protéger avec le roi et la tour
arrivant 1,5 et jettera où j'ai fait
d'abord être 5 la bande à win
bouftou
donc en fait fg c'est pas vraiment de
gaieté de joie mais de gaieté de coeur
c'est juste forcé
c'est juste complètement forcé
on dit car ou s'envoyer une sacrée
partie hier quand même s'il ne craque
pas sur un coup c'est un athlète
et là il aimait gaza est ce que ces
marrons poids icaro le joueur légendaire
i conneries ça peut passer
ça peut passer
quel genre de gaffe fericar ou dans les
prochains en fait c'est pas des gaves
c'est juste que la position peut se
détériorer
petit à petit coup par coup est en
réalité assez rapidement genre en
l'espace d'une dizaine de coups tu peux
passer de encore tenable à perdant sans
avoir fait la moindre grosse faute en
fait juste en étant pas très précis mais
il a même plus besoin de faire de faute
de gaffes entre guillemets pour perdre
la une ou deux imprécisions et c'est
perdu
et honnêtement
c'est dur quoi
y capri c'est fini je lis ça tu connais
peut-être pas la chanson capri c'est
fini
ces housses et capri rs et des idéaux et
aux révélations d'un large de naples ray
qui sont connus pour leur citron
n'empêche jura jeu toute la game en
première ligne à part deux trois coups
ouais après le truc c'est que les
25 premiers coups de la partie c'était
préparation donc il a fait 2 3 1
précision entre le coût 26 et 32 à deux
trois coups en dessous d'eux du coup
principal
eric hervo
il tombe dans le quart d'heure
je pensais qu'ils joueraient le fg fg
rapidement mais non il veut il veut
trouver mieux
bon je pense de toute façon il va faire
quelque chose comme objet tour g8
je pense aussi ouais j'avais tout juste
et puis après malgré tout peut-être à 5
po case
pour simplifier
tout ce qui est sur le dos de ricoh à
40% de chance je pense surtout à deux
victoires non je pense que 65 60 70 nuls
du coup 30 40 1
oui les web ou faire
ryle hésitent encore un
il réussit pas à trouver son rythme
aujourd'hui
il est obligé il est forcé il veut pas
le faire mais il est forcé
mais là on va voir firoud déjà arrivés
comme une furie
façon il était il était obligé ils
n'avaient vraiment pas le choix
il l'a fait
je pense à ça compte comme un match nul
est à 5 ans qui rêvait
comme prévu ok son programme échanges et
3 contre 2
sacrifie et trouver comment sacrifie et
le cavalier pour ghv fait il veut
rentrer dans tour fou contre tours ça ce
niveau là ils le font facilement ou pas
non par exemple concret qui se qualifie
à contrecoeur st il devait pas vraiment
parce que oui parce qu'on s'appelle
l'air la version de national tours
les versions gagnante qui était nulle au
début qui est devenu gagnante et qui
serait devenu way et bien sûr ce point
sur l'exemple
après faut essayer de la démarrer avec
une position
déjà pressante genre maxime quand il a
joué contre magnus il a eu tout faux
contre tours mais là il a vraiment pas
pu la pressé parce qu'ils sont rois
étaient trop loin
il ya une semaine en norvège
maintenant oui au
jour et y voit un échec roy bouge pour
eux quand ils défendent le pion eux et
puis peut-être eu quatre pour
regarder sur ses cadres y compris
peut-être prouve pour préparer à câble
et pour éventuellement défendeurs je
garde donc pour puncheurs
à quatre ce serait sympa si tu réussis
je pense que ce studio réussite aux
normes
et sur ces trois baies 3
je pense que ça vaut ça j'ai toujours
peur de laisser ce truc
je comprends
en dur de gagner une partie du jeu
d'échecs
et par curiosité je veux juste aller
voir puisque on dit qu'il ya une gaffe
de richard
met pas vraiment en fait
gough ce jusque l'une côté de moi
et c'est que très agréable ce que le
pionner sur un
quatuor bien sûr on y
va ok ça semaine passée
à huy bizarre
peut-être je sais pas peut-être s
attendait à l'épée trouvent parce que
douze jeux olympiques
tout cas bien jouer duda
moi
ça fait notre affaire en tout cas vlad
si doux d'apprendre
le demi point fabiano
va tout voir en fait si
vous gagnez le reste est ok on s'en fout
non bien sûr mais bon c'est bien que
caruana y
indiquer le vois pas trop qui va pas
trop loin
s'il arrive à + 4 ou 5 au bout d'un
moment tu auras beau gagner
c'est bien qu'ils se calment un peu
surtout qu'il ait eu deux fois les plans
fabiano
quand je fais des tours et fois entourée
entre 4
les points durs se trouvait ici mon
droit et est sûre ce 2
on pourrait peut-être même commencer par
mois ces deux réalités du 4e tour des
quatre
tours se jouent sous peu
et là et je suppose élevée 3/3
ouais
montrez un
en quoi on rajoute sept coups
sept coups
les résas il a raison de prendre son
temps par contre ce coup là il est
important et il ya beaucoup de
1,5 directe joëlle 5 direct
c'est pas con
maintenant elle est question aussi tours
joue vite je pense qu'il veut tour f1
oui à 8 h 6 tours de sa cage c'est ce
que je t'attrape le bouton
alsa l'auteur question alors qu'est ce
que je vais faire sur b4
presque il voit jouer au poker sega
maintien à quatre sont
bons
j'aime bien ce que dit le redis ces
trois bon je sais pas il faut faire
échec avant ou pas
par principe peut-être
en fait moi j'aime bien enlever le fou
comme ça
oui
[Musique]
et si geoffrey tour bruite avec le
détroit a déjà sur b3 pierre j'aurais pu
comprendre un an
howie collet soi que la cades
j'ai pas le temps de
rentrer voilà temps
quel dommage
donc un coup quoi bon en fait tu vas
faire ton pot 3 et puis donc avoir un
très bon souvenir à jouer tant g8
est-ce que tanger à ton tour g8 qui veut
tour f1 3,8 sur oa et h6 way attend il
veut bloquer sur blanc
il veut peut-être tour eiffe huit
tours à auchan avec l'idée juste pour
expliquer l idée surtout reprend prises
et de revenir bloqué sur case blanche et
même ça c'est questionnable en vrai
attend tour elle fait ainsi sa tension
blad
roddick et 8 c'est le pied ici et si je
prouve qu'ils offrent attends attends
c'est être gagnant ça si je bouffe je
joue au foot de 8 à 4,5 et puis je monte
mon droit
sur quatre
promenades g63 f7 ses farces et ross roi
singe
campath id ok peut-être ce que je sais
pas mais je montre aux ados tous trois
jeux 6
watts 2
à 1 5 4 c'est comme ça que
attends là on est on est pas loin là où
là on n'est pas loin les gens qui disent
que ces gagnants
je veux bien croire qu'avec une grosse
turbine soit gagnant ça se voit en fait
ils disent tout re 1 l'ordi explose à +3
donc à temps on va regarder tout re 1
menace le pion roi f7
ok j'ai pas honnêtement ça semble pas
loin mais c'est peut-être pas gagnant
j'ai pas taurin
non c'est pas c'est pas gagné en fait
ouais c'est cool si tu peux je tour
soeur
tu veux à 4 aïe ça c'était ici à quatre
fautes 2 5
ha ça c'est cool mais je comprends ce
qu'il a voulu faire écart ou s'est
attiré le pion à 6 pour bloquer sur case
blanche
ouais ça c'est hyper fort
parce que maintenant droit c'est
rouaroua f7 tour f 1 8 3 feet ça doit
gagner
we have the
way abandon ça ça gagne maintenant à
tort c'est un salaire formé en tout cas
c'est sûr qui vient d'améliorer sa
position alireza
et il lui reste 58 minutes il a le temps
ah ouais non là il peut en plus il peut
faire vraiment très mal il peut éliminer
un concurrent direct quasiment de la
course
il peut faire extrêmement mal
le prince ali
à deux doigts
et en plus ce qui serait vraiment bien
là tu sais qu'il a défendu deux fois de
position difficile s'il gagne sa
première bonne position ça fait quand
même du bien quoi
oui oui mais déjà
4 sur une telle préparation bien sûr si
pire
désagréable de partir sans un point dans
la poche est-ce que ça mérite un petit
mur d'aller la france ou les douches
pour une touche peut-être les punto
chhnang un mur de punto way aller le mur
de poche
pour les aider pour les pousser cela
donc tour c'est un tu dis qui a l'air
fort
après tout ça en fait le sualg couceiro
f7
ça permet reprendre jouer à quatre
épices à quoi je suis fou de doute ces
terrains mouais c'est l'élève le surcoût
pour ne pas perdre alors que ces gros
avantage non y'a des trucs contre touré
font maintenant et tout enfant
sage ou en quoi ta question si le fc
chooz b 4 3 3 car ils étaient trois ok
c'est sûr qu'il va tenir beaucoup aimé
voir tout ça dans
en amont c'est dur parce que là moi je
pense est fou et 3 ouais c'est tour f1
bonjour s à travers deux fois mais je
pense avoir le temps de faire ça
ok aussi et là des pièces quoi mais mais
bon ça va être difficile de défendre
non tour c1 c'est tour ça c'est déjà une
vraie option
après tout rachat c'est aussi un coup
parce que n'oublie pas que tu as aussi
détourage 5
qui peuvent arriver et il peut pas jouer
bref cette pour une raison de l'autre
c'est pas je pensais que c'était sept
niveaux de dose
oui et b4 tour f1 et c'est de nouveau la
même
connerie roi 8éme alentours c'est un
oui fait ça gagne tout de suite
c'est vrai coup le web mais pas facile à
voir
mais tout rachat en soit c'est un joli
coup aussi
bref cette fou des deux en fait c est à
4 tours f1 et maintenant la finale elle
gagne ça ait peu de fun non tout rachat
en fait c'est assez vicieux c'est
peut-être encore plus vicieux tour sert
en fait
parce que tu gardes quasiment toutes les
options
sauf que c'est hyper piégeurs
hockey lors du 2e tour g8 seul coup pour
nulle
mettons 8 menace rien vlad est ce que tu
fais tour g8 dans cette position après
tout rachat mois normal où il peut ouais
c'est dur de comprendre les démones
walid et c'est peut-être de football
ou non cb4 là dessus
et du coup quand tu fais tour c1 il a
tord pranger 4h cette tour h4 ça l'idée
ok mais ça c'est hyper dur et si je fais
j'ai 5 du coup maintenant wife set ça
passe parce que sur tours c1 il a le
temps de faire tous ces 8
ok c'est hyper dur en fait tout rachat
ça peut juste gagner parce que tour g8
avec l'idée en fait l'idée tour g8
d'avoir un moment donné sur b4 tour
c'est un tout ranger 4 c
et s'il tourache entourage tweet
je pense food et 2
2 4 mais en fait c'est de nouveau la
même
à il fait tour f1 d'abord et pourquoi
pas un tour c'est un tu peux pas se
trouve ouais et tour f1 c'est quoi la
c3 est
fou c'est un riche
et g5 un g6
doré français alors préféré maxime bref
salut toi ça coupe le roi fameux
troubled
pour intel
est
dur à dire
non mais le problème de tours de tours
g8 les gars secteur g8 ne menacerait en
fait regardez juste regardé la séquence
de coûts en fait il vient de faire droit
à 8 h 6 tours f8 pour gagner la colonne
et ramener le roi et si surtout rachat
le coup c'est tour g8 c'est impossible
en fait c'est juste qu'on explique
souvent avec mad si la tour venait pas
de chez eux ce serait quelque chose oui
mais faire tour g8 pour chasser la tour
et surtout rachat revenir en c1
quasiment à faisable en fait donc tout
rachat je pense que d'un point de vue
pratique s'il a tous les coups ça gagne
en fait
et dingli rennes complètement gagnant et
ça peut être une bonne journée un
hobo ont dit non
il faut comprendre que tant g8 vite j'ai
quatre oui et ça c'est quasi
introuvables en fait surtout avec 12
minutes
d'ailleurs la mort vous va faire tout
achat la main veut faire c'est un groupe
très manuelle
alors dit de ne plus 5 pour dink
et mais c'est peut-être avec des
turbines très poussées mais c'est ça le
thème des amateurs avec les dévaluations
c'est que tu peux avoir des positions
qui donnent même plus 20 et c'est
quasiment introuvable en fait ouais
parce que l'ordinateur voix à tes tae ho
disions voilà
away
après faut pas qu'il fasse très fluide
et qu'ils se trompent et qui rate 5 4
et maxime est pas au tournoi un an
maxime s'est pas qualifié il n'est pas
passé loin contre rapporte mais
bon il était un peu
il était un peu moins fort sur cette
séquence de qualification
en tout cas là c'est une excellente
partie aujourd'hui
d'un l'iresa en plus ça donne tellement
de confiance de gagner ça peut changer
tellement de choses ils jouent contre
qui demain
il reprend les noirs je me rappelle mais
je sais plus contre eux qui
va demain après demain d'ailleurs
après ce moment et il voit
dur
très dur même
ce que max aurait eu ses chances pour
les candidats évidemment un s'ils y
étaient il aurait eu ses chances après
toujours pas ceux qui sont qualifiés
mérite d'y être quoi en soi après c'est
sûr que s'il était là il aurait eu ses
chances
forcément un
s'est tellement resserré à haut niveau
que tout le monde a ses chances
et mvele pas moins que les autres
et partir sur une victoire avant le jour
de repos c'est vrai qu'en plus c'est
bien pour
pour récupérer
il est confiant à la caméra il a ça son
visage confiant hissé non qu'il est très
proche de gagner là
c'est sûr
par contre oui
[Musique]
je dois dire que comprendre que tours 8
gagne pas c'est pas des choses les plus
dans trois
mines haletant
et aussi il écrire tout rachat le plus
fort mais tout ça aussi c'est hyper
content
moi je suis sûr que dans la partie de
moi personnellement j'ai fait tout ça
pour élargir
le confie le conflit oui
le pire dans l'histoire c'est son nom il
aurait mérité d'y être mais en fait tous
ceux qui sont pas qualifiés méritent pas
d'y être en fait c'est aussi simple que
ça
là-dessus il n'y a pas de noms
des qualifiés tu mérites diakité pas
qualifiés c'est que c'était passé un bar
en fait une voiture je mérite aussi en
quelque sorte je pourrais prendre
d'autres reprendre les vols je pourrai
prendre ma mais tu pourrais un hand
soit sur tout sauf sur thouet mais bon
il y avait qu'à se qualifier s'il se
qualifie pas c'est qu'ils méritent pas
surtout qu'il ya quand même beaucoup de
tournois sur lesquels tu peux te
qualifier
radja rajab à écouter raf jaoui livré à
sauvez moi qu'est-ce qu'une fois ici -
il se qualifiait pour les quotas
il ay la fois
les peurs du coeur de la finale
contre tings opposants et sinon il avait
gagné je pense qu'entre les points
perdus contre qu'il a
gagné le combat
il faut pas oublier que dans ceux qui
auraient fui à don après il ya des
questions politiques etc mais cariat
qu'ils n'en soient sur l'échiquier il
aurait mérité d'y être aussi dire par là
que ça compense entre guillemets enfin
pour ceux qui pensent que radjabov
machin est tout et ça enlève bon ok mais
on a encore enlevé un joueur là
il a fait enfin f8
raté ouais
me
le pire c'est que je pense que ça doit
être nul
forcément
faire tout rachat parce qu'il devait
garder les tours sur l'échiquier
quel dommage
c'est un gros raté quand même ça
écart où il a tout calculé en plus
car oui la france a gagné à huy faute de
8 à 4 jeu
5-7
roi jeu 7 g 6 allez on a trois sur le
coup
peu importe qu'elle court mais plus au
popb
c'est ouf l'ordinateur au fondeur 40 y
trouve nulle
kessé du bol quand même c'est vraiment
du bol
dans ses patients en fait on peut pas
savoir on peut pas savoir s'il va gagner
parce qu'il l'a pas assez sur
genre ça résout gang à la longue
les f4
si on règle le problème normal ans et
que tu peux pas monter jusqu'à cavaliers
f4 à chaque fois tu montes par ou
comment tu rentres en fait
la question c'est ce qu'ils vont trouver
après par la force des choses ou pas
là qui est en train de regarder sur
l'ordinateur c'est vraiment compliqué
très intense où trouves pas parce que le
problème c'est croix des trois cavaliers
4,24 points f4 roi de katia b4 puis on
prend à trois et on n'a pas le temps de
d'aller faire ce truc là
c'est quand même très questionnable mais
il car on peut aussi se tromper
d'ailleurs parce que quand j'ai regardé
c'était très souvent seul coup pour les
noirs genre là par exemple à quatre
c'est vraiment le seul coup je pense
qu'il va jouer parce que domaine pion à
sa part est stupide mais réfléchie
fabienne que je dis quand même que c'est
plus 0,2 profondeur soit sembla d'
pas moi j'ai l'impression que mon ordi
c'est rond point fait c'est nul il est
donc avant par maintenant il donne un
avantage décisif mais il
[Musique]
donc jardy doit se tromper
des fois qu'ils fassent ça qu'il te mets
king rosseeva et après quand tu fouilles
mais les profondeurs combien là
va falloir laisser tourner coup par coup
il ya peut-être une manière mais ils
trouveront jamais c3 mais en fait le
truc c'est qu'ils peuvent la tournée
pendant longtemps est tombé par hasard
dessus
c'est ça le truc dans ces finales c'est
que si ces gagnants tu peux trouver par
hasard on
s'est un peu comme la finale mvl caruana
d'ailleurs il ya vécu de manière de
gagner la tournée une fois il n'a pas
trouvé deux fois il n'a pas trop eu
trois fois il n'a pas trouvé la
quatrième il a trouvé assez juste qu'il
a essayé une méthode de méthodes trois
méthodes et puis au final
battu
par la force des choses tu trouve en
fait
grâce qui rassure ans et qui car où il
réfléchit après fou des huit
le total look wikio et ne peut pas
éviter la formation des plus rage ce jeu
6 ouais mais en fait la leur dîme la
tiens donc en fait c'est du pur ball en
fait si fait nul
et c'est du pur ball si bien dit rezaï
les gagnantes en fait c'est vraiment eu
jette une pièce 50% ça les raisins qui
gagne 50% ces écarts ou c'est pas une
question de calcul ou quoi c'est
vraiment dû jeter pièce
façon il est obligé de jouer à 4 1 si tu
fais par quatre tu perds juste instante
non
et d'ailleurs c'est vrai d'ailleurs
est-ce que qu'est ce qui s'passe situe
au jour à 4
si tu vois à broc et le puits en direct
bref ces trois jeux 6
bof bof bof faut 2 2 en fin de 5e 5
en fait tu te retrouves dans cette
finale à tekken tu peux plus prendre
parce que tu as pu le contre jeu avec b
4 à 4 que j'aime jouer rattray
et moi je met le fond f6 non pas
quelqu'un mathew galluzo connais quoi
je pensais passer comme ça mais en fait
je suis bloqué russie a oui ok je joue
rouages ces trois jeux 6 cuil
peut-être la seule idée que tu te rends
menton mais le roi c'est sûr que je le
ramène sur le quatrième
c'est bien ça le problème
est là tu as plus de coups ouais parce
que si tu vois tout ça si tu fais trois
wave 3 c'est fini
ok ça il peut se tromper parce que si
les noirs pearl de los rios à ils seront
pas du coup nous rejoue comme le roi
doit revoir ses dépenses et sur jeu
quand c'est contre eux j'ai mes entrées
en avant tout à l'heure où quand le roi
montilla 4 b 4 à ba3 dehors donc en fait
c'est pour ça qu'il faut absolument
faire à quatre essais 3 pour créer un
pion passé à la temps pour faire nul
ok c'est pas si facile en fait c'est
bien joué de la part d' ali reza quand
même parce qu'il ya qu une seule manière
de défendre pour hikaru et peut-être que
même là ils jettent une pièce
d'internautes ne sait pas que les au
moment critique de la partie
peut-être pas que le moment critique de
ce tournoi peut être celle où on
critique de sa carrière gagner une
finale
wima privat se vanter qu'il est très bon
final il va pas travailler tu nous as
dit
donc d'être faut qu'ils ratent
aurait front a gagné à la fin quand le
pion sera en 3 laurent f3 en fera food
et 4 vous prend 1,3
on a quelques où on est au 38e en gros
le là il reste un magicien comme une
autre pour faire un coup mais on
s'est salués à 4 faudra
trois oui
donc 2
ces trois ça le court numéro 41 ah ouais
donc un coup il a à faire
après le coup 41 sait jamais un peu
facile
à jouer
ce sera encore un autre problème allez
en tout cas c'est le moment décisif la
de la partie ça peut se décider sur ce
coup
ça peut être ce coup là
qui décident d'une partie de ses
candidats en tout cas qui pourrait
propulser alireza en tête du classement
après le truc c'est qu'on sait qu'ils
car où il n'a pas la défense en fait
c'est vraiment ils jettent une pièce là
c'est grave
oui c'est hyper mauvais comme
sa grimace sévère on doit pas être bien
sur le stream d'hikaru actuellement
stream compliqué
sassus
concentré comme jamais en sueur
ben non il est pas bien
voilà
les expressions tronche y allons nous
dit dans le chat dans là c'est vraiment
des expressions faciales
il doit être en train d'analyser la
position vlad en ce moment
il est pas bien il a pas 3-0 mcknight
pense que quoi qu'il arrive au père
will sais pas en fait ils cherchent eux
c'est pas qu'il coule votre boîte mail
sur quels points ils arrivent à avoir à
quatre [ __ ] un oiseau lécher un peu
énervé il a vraiment du bol l'a
parfois à quoi non il va le faire
regarde il regarde c'est sûr qu'il va
jouer ils pensent que ça permet ça tient
par la chance incroyable
quelle horreur oh ça dégoûte
c'est tellement pas mérité s'il fait nul
il a trouvé regardant mais là il trouve
enfin là il trouve au hasard en fait à
quatre c'est le coup le plus logique
mais il veut même pas le jouer parce
qu'il pense que ça perd il le fait au
nom
ça dégoûte vraiment en fait n'est ce pas
ouais ok mais aussi les noirs dont ce
pion le port en tout cas tellement
évident non mais gère le fait qu'ils
pensent que ces perdants et que ça
tienne ça dégoûte parce que là c'est
vraiment de la chance
on met à faire bref c'est là toute façon
il n'a pas le choix et achète g6 non
pourtant moi par exemple avec les noirs
je suis sûr que
même est lui aussi alireza aussi tout le
monde est sûre est juste il est une
chance incroyable et je veux dire parce
que
c'est incroyable en fait
c'est vraiment la chance
vraiment la chance ça existe en face aux
échecs ça a toujours été comme ça
la réussite fait partie prenante du jeu
comme dans tous les sports
qui touche le poteau ça tombe de
centimètres plus à l'intérieur c'est
dedans c'est comme ça hein
c'est comme ça pas forcément tu en
profites pas apprécié non mais bon fin
même hikaru pense qu'il est perdant faut
réfléchir des fois
des monts et pour ça il faut avoir joué
aux échecs pour comprendre ce truc là
c'est comme ça
mais bon il faut qu'il ait lu ces trois
ans corps et ton ordi n'arrive pas à
trouver y trouve plus rien on y trouve
toujours
il trouve plus rien du
hc trois jeux 7 g 6 7 3 non pourquoi
pressé par exemple coller ce droit aux
assauts de sa fougue
5,5 à 6 voies de trois collèges quatre
échecs ouais c'est ça le truc l'excision
le noir veulent pas jouer collectif
mais si ces échecs ça peut aller et du
coup y apprend impressionnant un peu cia
le roi-père
vois je suis 3,2 me lie à beaucaire
donc tout se joue sur cet été du contre
jour ou bien alors sur les docks
même ça ça
aurait pu ne pas tenir
mais sans répit julia juste à 10 ans qui
s'est encore échec
n'aurait pas été un échec ça tient pas
en fait
qu'avaliser de d'ailleurs
mais j'ai en fait si c'est pas sûr échec
ça tient pas
c'est marrant qu'il soit levé avec deux
minutes à la pendule avant le 40e
ils auraient pu le vivre aurait pu peut
tomber là il a peut-être pas il a
peut-être mal noté
je pense qu
il est sûr qu'il le voie pour voir faire
lui avoir pissé en deux minutes
ce que veut dire
pis vite et les toiles sont très proches
ces trois tempo
à ça dégoûte à sallèles dégoûte c'est
sûr qu'il arrive
en gros c est la fin
lassé finirait et a malheureusement il
arrive à faire fuir donc
race est cette fois ce quoi apprendre a
eu de la réussite sur les deux jours
avant qu'on peut pas se plaindre non
plus
ça quand même très bien tourner les
autres jours donc quelque part ça
équilibre
et à temps et un truc comme ça
vision floue g5
ça
je vous laisse un métal tendre fera des
pronostiqueurs tu peux pas prévu ni
colère cattani colette
ya aucune manoeuvre
n'y a pas eu besoin bien dans et ça
ça ça ou 5
à 8 g partance ou c'est un dieu
on s'est uni qu'on la pose
c'est unique ray
et ça
il faut toujours la même chose le sol
et pantalons fille
s'est unie comme un truc quelle réussite
mais quand même oui c'est très bien pour
les amateurs vous voyez alors à quel
point le koleos interprète fort
et 86,3 comme ça ne peut pas bouffer 5
ils contrôlent eux cinq convois euros un
peu parce
ces prochaines facilement
du pian 2 5 ils contrôlent f4 pour avoir
échec sur 4 hero 2 3 et 4 et 6 pour quoi
pour qui n'est jamais propre site c'est
incroyable ce qu elle est carrément en
octobre
et ils voudront le c3 la fin et il
contrôle en b cats il va avoir ses 2 et
d3 la fin pour faire à l'échelle dans la
variante de fou quoi mais ça c'était
impossible à prévoir pour ali reza en
fait
ouais ouais ça pour ça bien sûr aux
critiques près de tours et b4 il n'ya
pas fou c'est un
à ça va toujours être la même chose on
les fera taire tous ceux
à ça dégoûte
lundi 12 je le sais
les gens qui n'ont en revanche pas
froisser de la réussite mais c'est foot
par comprendre que c'est de la réussite
que ça cian gens comprennent pas ça je
sais même pas comment expliquer en fait
dans ce registre web c'est toi tu peux
écouter et l'eau il est très rare que
lecavalier qui n'est pas une pièce très
mobile est aussi efficace qui contrôle
toutes les cases des plus importants de
l'échiquier ce qu'on a essayé de bons
moments entre à quelques minutes donc à
ces rapaces que lecavalier
bourse
est fier les deux pions là on
al'impression qu'avec le fou qui
contrôle la diagonale il suffit juste
qu'il se retrouve sur la diagonale
effrayer le poids mais il peut pas en
fait que ce cette attaque contrôle voici
ce à des contrôles routiers sont des
contrôles ces trois des contrôles il ya
toujours et est aussi qu'on leur en
arrivant des trois cavaliers en cas
d'échec qui marchent pascal chauvin qui
est légal elle est le dernier détail
bien sûr c'est vraiment
et vous avez bien vu que hikaru lui-même
en fait il n'avait pas compris que ça
tenait ce voyez en fait mais bon
et rares ces échanges des tours mais
après tu as tellement envie de le faire
hikaru il n'a pas si bien défendu en
réalité
la très mal défendu m
il a réussi deux passes et d'un petit
avantage aux pommes away grand perdant
quatre coups et
steffi casse
et là du coup et ça tombe comme ça mais
ça arrive
mais même nature bing se tromper de bain
c'est pour dire à quel point c'est dur
c'est comme ça
enfin même remarque pour ali reza ben
ali reza il a plutôt fait une bonne
partie quand même bonne prépare début de
la finale il a fait une imprécision
après il a bien joué la tannerie tombe
là dessus il a pas de réussite mais ça
arrive mais je sais pas c'est comme si
tu as 30 mètres tu mets une frappe et
soit elle tombe dans la lucarne cela
tombe sur le poteau en fait mais tu as
fait la même frappe toi personnellement
mais ces footeux pas comprendre en fait
les échecs c'est comme toute activité
humaine comme on ne peut pas tout
contrôler il ya de la réussite mais ça
les gens sont incapables de le
comprendre pense que les gens calculent
tout de a à z
pourtant quand on y est heureuse c'est
vrai problème en commencer car de la
miss on voit sur jose way est
aujourd'hui la meilleure en c3 c'est le
goût qui a permis aux loups noirs de ce
sourire parce qu'il n'a jamais
c'est vrai aussi
mais bon globalement il a dominé la
patrie a sûrement beaucoup de
droit ces deux surexcités logique mais
c'est son imprécision de la partie
d'avoir un peu traîné mais bon après
tourcoing et puis je pense pas que ce
soit une erreur en soit d'un point de
vue pratique
sauf que bien sûr il avoue play off ou
2,57 je suis
non oui mais je veux dire alireza paris
compte tours et fitou on n'a jamais
critiqué pour ça je pense pas
même fut moyen de se tromper en fait y'a
plus rien moyen de faire c'est juste nul
et ses sacs en plus c'est vraiment pas
de problème je regardais même pas de
piège
ça aurait pu continuer à être difficile
à défendre mais là c'est juste nul et
nul
ne sait ce que je
peux
nadia
m'a écouté je pense que c'est plus
proche de nous que
je suppose que x 6 x 6 damas et six dans
le cadre
c'était d'ailleurs parfois six
l'a fait il a fait
ouais bon après ça avec sur les trois
points appartient et demi sur trois il
est pas mal de payer non plus
c'est le score logiquement
jusqu'ici euros bien que ce soit ça va
bien
et fait voir un caruana qu'on a à
l'écran
assez nul un peu plus facile
nous ici
et que ding en fait à part qu'on termine
que tu crois c'est très intéressant
où les charges les dents je pense quand
on gagne facilement
vient d échange pour ce
qui est de toute manière on doit faire
quelque chose comme dame de dents bush
hager g et puis c'est clair qu'il
est noir vaut rien
peut-être fait roi g2 ta meuf trois
tours 17
danbé 7
et si je commence par la tour
oui en fait j'ai un peu sous estime rico
voir brad pitt au top pour voir
matériaux fouet
n'a pas le temps d'être le futur des
cats est bloquée ça peut être gagnant
il a compris là
il est maintenant dans les situations de
[Musique]
à partir
exactement et
d'ailleurs oui aujourd'hui
quand elle est mauvaise et tekken road
qu'on a des les prix sur le fil
c'est le même coeur important + 37 hier
l'auteur a merdé autres
il ya un peu en fait y'a plus d'erreurs
à faire je pense qu'il ya même beaucoup
de gens moins fort qui ferait plus
d'erreurs avec les mars qui a plus
d'erreurs en fait
on va sur son avocat non non il ya plus
grave affaire c'est que des coûts forcé
cité réussi jusqu'ici ça y est
racontée ici
la porte et qui parmi vos les
spectateurs auraient pu offrir une
seconde car ce n'est encore pas de bol
ce que frau h4 composant le chat parce
qu'il ya pas cavaler f4f cissé sur le
5-fu g3 et permet des f4 sale coup
l'égérie à chaque fois il ya un seul
truc à chaque fois ça tient coi c'est
tellement improbable
en fait pas beau c'est coloré c'est 3 c
est cher ouais
et un truc comme ça
tout ce que tu veux au cours avec le
rejet
ils sont anti prix donné gagnant là on
arrive à tomber d'un encore
d'autres moyens quand l'ordinateur dont
un gagnant oui comment savez
vous bouger les pièces sommes
les anglais sans point en championnat
lisait tu peux être sûr que l'ordinateur
se trompe
en finale ça arrive de temps en temps
qu'il fasse h et pas trop pourquoi
mais ça arrive qui donne une évaluation
complètement parce que selon les étapes
se positionner
vous savez tous ces gagnants il arrive
pas
et si je fais prise car à les prendre à
la qui a aidé 5 roi des huns tout de
suite saint croix la
date a
toujours
témoigné
[Musique]
dans mon bureau
et si je mets le fou en d2 tu auras
cavaliers sept
jours
j'ai surtout une beauté de ce feu
une excuse vertes seront pervers parce
qu'en fait c'est vrai c'est horrible
il faut s'être carey price est
malheureusement
à ça dégoûtant fait
ils nous mentent ou bien sûr c'est de
jouer
c'est
neuf
pour jouer plus tard
oui oui c'était normal qu elle se trouve
au pouvoir je fous ce 9
ça rend fou
la bonne nouvelle c'est que du coup il
va pas se dire qu'il doit plus
travailler les finales
il va pas se dire qu'il doit plus
donc il ya du positif
tiens je trouve une 13e victoire comme
ça
[Musique]
et x 5 ça marche pas à cause de prises
b2 prise b2e 5-fu ces trois cavaliers
prendre on apprend et leucate
et là encore un ses hôtes en prêt
car il ya trois colonnes l'homme
de dégoûter
tu penses c'est quelqu'un qui va réussir
à faire + 4 dans ce tournoi ça paraît
tellement dur de gagner une partie et
charlie warm up boys peuvent deux fois
ça va devenir facile quand les warm pool
secondes
l'inde a déjà commencé à composer pour
d'autres
mais il est vrai maintenant il est dur
de voir quelqu'un dehors que justement
c'est possible
ouais super rapide par exemple au
web vignes où il a joué à 2020
fournisseurs ah oui il fait jouer même
plus polisseur du bonheur
ici alors un rade japon et je vais
d'ailleurs ajourd'hui dossier on voit
mal pourquoi coup les rapports très bas
tu vois donc je ça c'est bien parce
qu'on va jouer les deux avec les blancs
côté ferroudja retour mais on jouera
peut-être un peu tôt n'ont conduit des
neuf et donc trois rounds couler les
trois rondes 3 les deux revoir ma bruges
a donc commencé
irujo je pense qu'il peut battre n'est
pas avec les noirs
ou trop solide encore
sauf que
sauf que bien sûr ne pourrait dans une
telle position qui doit pas vouloir trop
risqué
de mon
job pense il ya beaucoup si le voir sur
quel site rien je pense ya beaucoup plus
de chances trouve un truc qu'on foute
sans cacher que pour la société
je pense
bien
ça va paraître banale parce que bien
avec l'exemple du couffo ses neuf c'est
que ça monte le génie de ce jour parce
que s'il n'y a pas de wii / vite sorti
le foot on est rentré fort qu'eux donc
ça va casser
l'équilibré l'équilibré se joue là qui
est basée sur l'égalité qui
pensait tomber au hasard ça à force de
l'envoyeur je pense que c'est bien
travailler parce que en dames pas mal
d'essayer que les y aurait cette fois
ils ont compris que ça casse
ding ils disent très mal autant
il est prêt pour les changements les
conditions un nom
elle vient de jeux de mots comme
ici dans ce sens
c'était dix sur dix aurait rajouté des
janus
il connaît les janus
la mélange d'une dame et d'un cavalier
un janus
c'est son vrai nom en fait
belle pièce le janus il peut faire mal
salle d'ailleurs
le janus pas
la seule pièce qui pourrait mater seul
film en rêve cet aileron réfuté le janus
matt
belles pièces non
tu contemples le janus sur l'échiquier
ici oh bah oui oh bah oui un janus sur
g8 ça règle le problème en
belles pièces bon bah si tu avais un
janus santé 8 excusez moi monsieur
d'ailleurs tu pourrais faire janus e6
double attaque
là tu ferais un janus comme ça et du
coup tu ferais échec au roi est un
très très fort le janus ces belles
pièces
jeanine g8 pour faire maths mais je
pense que si tu as un janus a envie de
la jouer avec un petit peu encore quand
même c'est pas tous les jours
situation qu'il
termine la partie vide
moi je crois que je tape dans mon
fauteuil je vais très énervé futur
j'efface vite et je pars
mais je serai très énervé là parce qu'il
ya plein de gens
m'en fous je suis vraiment sur ça me
rend fou
ça m'énerve en fait je me dis que le jeu
est très mal équilibré que c'est un jeu
de merde
et qu'il faut réfléchir à arrêter quoi
l'adage
il est assis je pense qu'il a tout
compris et désillusions
en brèche trakl
donnerait son intérêt d'un four prend
son propre cavaliers % seulement janus
ah bah non mais janus beaucoup trop fort
le janus est au dessus tout les amis
il faut jamais sous-estimer un janus
et ça a dégoûté un petit peu après
on a quand même eu beaucoup de balles
hier contre rapporte est en quelque
sorte
ça équilibre un petit peu
la réussite d'alireza quoi
ça équilibre un petit peu la réussite
d'alireza
du janus une pièce qui restera dans les
annales oui
complètement
complètement honnêtement
tentant vlad ils disent le janus une
pièce qui restera dans les annales
va très heureux
particularité m gla sur 10
à 8 sur 10 pour ali reza 6 pour les
quarts où
mes matches nuls
là pour moi c'est vraiment le cas de
figure où ali reza il joue quasiment
parfait
et il fait ouais il fait il fait une
super prépare quand même donc 10 sur 10
la prépa
et 6 sur 10 la finale un peu mieux que
la moyenne quand même parce que le truc
doit gagner et hikaru l'ouverture
vingt cinq du coût
et la finale sept ouais ça mérite pas
plus parce que ça tient juste pas
réussit
mais bon on était obligé de mettre un
peu plus parce que ça met des points
voilà prêt pass 5 pas ce qu'il s'est
vraiment fait dominer dans l'ouverture
il ya une mauvaise finale
donc tu peux pas m
[Musique]
tu peux pas mettre plus que 5 après la
finale qui peut pas mettre plus que sept
donc si sûr disent ouais c'est pas une
mauvaise note 6 sur 10 en fait
n'oubliez pas qu'il doit perdre en fait
ils passent
enfin il ya deux moments où il n'est pas
bien quand même
et à la fin ils n'avaient pas vu qu'à
quatre essais 3 tenait sa tombe parce
que ça tombe
jusqu'à 25 ans mais en fait il s'est
juste pour dire des faux truc enfin si
c'est juste pour transformer les phrases
c'est pas la première fois que je vois
un troll et faire dire l' inverse de ce
qu on dit c'est bon d'être en fait ça
rien à faire ici si c'est pour sous les
lire n'importe quoi pendant tous les
lives
on a dit que ça passait jusqu'à 26 50 27
ces prépas ça faisait trop mal et ça
gagner quasiment sur l'échiquier et que
contre 27,50 28 c'était beaucoup plus
dur
mais là
c'est pas passer ça arrive hein
prévenir quelqu'un à -1 ouais mais bon
enfin
après le problème c'est que il fait tour
f 800 comprendre que la finale est nul
et il a permis aux blancs de
d'avancé sur l'échiquier
c4 c'était pape apprécié du tout en fait
fallait absolument faire 5 pour sur gk
de faire droit aux 6 et sur h5 du coup
cavaliers 6 il n'a pas vu ce set up
défensif qui était le sata qui faisait
nul plus ou moins en force
donc il a raté le bon set-up et après il
a fait plusieurs coups un peu de côté
dans la mauvaise direction et
l'ajusterait fuite ils voient pas que la
finale est nul en amont donc si elle
perd il pas une finale nul à une finale
perdant cinq coups et surtout rachat le
seul coup pour défendre c'était tour g8
et ça il aurait pas eu
donc mais bon si sur dix c'est pas une
mauvaise note en fait c'est au dessus de
la moyenne c'est une pas une mauvaise
partie en fait mais on peut pas mettre
plus que six
parce qu'en fait si ce tour f il gagne
et qui perd il aurait eu trois ou quatre
sur dix donc c'est normal de m 6 les
réserves trouve 7,8 toit s est mérité
aussi puisque il fait super prépa la
finale s'était pas excellent mais ça
mérite quand même un peu plus que la
moyenne dans le sens où ça aurait dû
gagner voilà quoi
en fait personne en fait ce que personne
commence et qui caro a de la chance que
tu aurais fuites soient forcés etienne
ouais mais ce qui me l'a total combien
des lots je crois que tu es 2002 non
tu es plus de 2000 et comme tu as joué
en tournoi et touba tu peux le
comprendre mais en fait quelqu'un qui
est amateur il est incapable de
comprendre ce genre de choses enfin où
certains font exprès mais c'est normal
en fait citer 2002 c'est sûr que tu vas
comprendre que tous réfutent ces
c'est du hockey ça tombe bien par hasard
et c'est comme ça en fait c'est là c'est
comme ça ce jeu
23 64 mais oui je vois que le chat
dauphine bas web et 23 64 en fait tu
sais jouer aux échecs quoi déjà donc tu
sais pas tu comprends déjà de quoi ça
parle mais à mille quatre cent mille 500
tu peux pas comprendre en fait et c'est
normal que tu puisses pas comprendre
mais par contre c'est fou de contredire
et de penser que tu as une science
infuse alors que
le niveau de n'importe quel bon joueur à
l'âge de 4 ans quoi
ça c'est fou
wattiez de retour
les échecs comme pendant les dernières
cinq minutes réflexion n'a qu'à passer
d'une des aspirations de total ouais
elle est confiée
en fait je devais pas croire que ça
pouvait tenir et après quand il a
regardé concrètement il a vu que ça
tenait
mais même la première fois qu'il a voulu
jouer à quatre ils étaient encore en
mode désespéré et quand la deuxième fois
il a fait ça du camp et ça s'est vu
qu'en l'espace de 2 minutes 30 il a
compris ça change à l'espace de deux
minutes et ouais ya pensé que ça permet
à prix là il a compris que c'était nul
c'est peut-être quand elle a vu que les
défauts rj45 fauché trois mêmes
pentagone
il a dû voir une variante qui pensaient
qu'ils perdaient la résoudre et
s'ignorent pantaloni
voulais tellement pas de jouer way et
après il a compris que ça te met
d'ailleurs d'après ce que je veux ou les
finales
c'est une grande faiblesse c'est cette
génération fantastique des jaunes indien
merci eric est ici
prague lamballe les autres émirats où
les autres ça reste toujours le
reprendra chez le siège
mais ils sont jeunes aussi par mois il
est il arrive pourtant les gens qui sont
élevés pour cette phrase du jour mais
beaucoup plus rarement pour tout cas
pour d'autres choses
comme quoi les finales ceni
positionnelle ni les calculs mais toutes
les fois
ouais
bon après il faudra vraiment qu'il soit
dans l'optique il devait faut pas qu'ils
s'énervent 3d reza et qui se disent
après la partie j'ai pas assez proches
disent ok tu aurais dû perdrière tu
aurais dû gagner aujourd'hui deux nuls
et la vie continue n'en pense l approche
à avoir parce que sinon ça peut vraiment
mettre un coup au moral
parce que hier quand même lourd même si
roy 4 c'était une sacrée erreur il a
quand même eu du bol alireza que ce soit
pas plus simple à gagner après parce que
vu la position en fait ça aurait pu
gagner
sans effort pour y envoyer vos potes
victoires automatiques ouais c'est ça
mais il a eu du bol parce que ça aurait
pu au serviteur automatique ça aurait
même mérité d'être
ça fait nul entre dingli rennais
rapporte aussi
a donc oui comme je dis ici avec les
dames sûrement sur l'échiquier le noir
réussissent faut deux gladiateurs
c'était nul alors oui ce qu il ne l est
pas bien joueur
gère
non non il ne faut pas permettre ça
tombe bien avant l'heure
oui
non avant
à deux ans à leur grosse faute
méthodique mois par an il fallait
absolument que l'adour reste sur des
rires et
peu importe un j'ai envie de dire
d'ailleurs la photo
inexplicable parce que ça c'est facile à
comprendre que ça c'est vraiment facile
comment il a beaucoup plu aux à
regretter d'ailleurs manqué
que 0
et je crois ça joue toujours et jamais
sûr du résultat
ok c'est que le 40e donc je crois qu'ils
n'ont pas le droit de proposer nul avant
le 40e
je pense qu'ils pouvaient pas faire nul
techniquement
oui mais ça c'est toujours pas compris
que ce sera pareil
est ce que tu veux qu'on fasse le récap
express de la partie même si elle n'est
pas finie parce qu'on sait que ça va
faire nul
bon niveau
donc l'objectif c'est de faire des récap
entre 5 et 10 minutes max de toute la
partie
de toute façon là on est d'accord ça va
faire nul ok alors plus rien on
expliquera juste pourquoi ici ça fait
nul et c'est tout
à
écoute
j'espère que ludwig est là parce qu'il
doit faire un temps fort et après on est
parti de toute façon c'est à peu près ce
qu'on dit
exprès mais alors une vie gay la lettre
k way one two three
bon des quatre prévisible parce que
quand quelqu'un joue au plan
systématique moi donc ça donne les
filles de nettoyer les dégâts d'accueil
cicatrices que les strophes c'est le
répertoire de carreaux des piqûres
sélestadienne
d'aller compétition sérieuse et on va
voir qui carreaux va suivre ça variant
de fétiches pendant très longtemps comme
il en a l'habitude vestes moirées ce
mois les résas a eu quelques parties
avec eux trois les trois petits chevaux
de troie donc ça a était sur moi
avant d'un côté cette ue était sûrement
préparé par un carreau de leur côté ça
devrait dire qu ils voient pas l'offrir
ici dans ce dom cette position est
apparu dans les pratiques de figeac sûrs
quand les jaune et noir 1,4 wafou prend
ces trois dames princes et rois la
variante à la mode à haut niveau dans la
nive zoo l'idée c'est qu'on gagne la
paire de fou mais et noir réussissent à
être contrôlé le centre rapidement se
développer et
les décès situe au prince sur 2,5 avec
les des oeufs de poule 5 l'idée ce qui a
précédé ses pas eu de vainqueur de 4
d'heure ça a été une grosse des bars à
nantes à l'époque pour ne permettant pas
alors du coup que les rouleaux le
kobaïen donc faucheux cinq
dessins avant que les besoins en jeu
droit pour que les bandes sont forcés de
reprendre avec les dents baissier ce
matin pour gagner beaucoup de temps pau
à chaud sans la dame avec le fou comme
ça d'ailleurs un des groupes le
fouillent dans
4 pourquoi pour que le cavalier 2.8
bouge pas sûr de cette posture de fouet
aux prises six quatre dames c'est les
noirs viol alors moins de la tour sur
2,8 et puis pour c'est sur ce 5 et
attend qu est-ce que les bonbons frère
parce qu'un début toutes les branches
collèges 3 après trois haies et après
peuvent se marier avec g3 g2 pour cacher
roy gh3 rouages de son là dessus il a
fait cavalier f3 tour des huit à
développement et dames ces deux là
surprise à
d'alireza l'idée c'est de replacer la
dame sur cette case pour maintenant
jouer le 4 et quand on jouera le 5 on
tapera sur le cavalier qui pourra taper
sur la dame a noté que la dame est moins
bien placés en deux sets parce qu'elle
peut plus aller vers bessette comme
possible il est possible dans d'autres
variantes c5 pour taper le centre est
important que dans ces deux est un coup
très rare joué que 3 fois et que yann en
écho aux portes joueurs parfois c'est la
prépa donc eu quatre pour jouer eux cinq
est touché le cavalier fou prend f1 est
ici tours.fr parce que dans certaines
variantes pas comme on va le voir ici
les noirs jouent g5 alors il faut jouer
5 parce qu'on a eu 5 et sur ce geste qui
aurait pu on prend attaque la dame donc
j'ai cinq direct cavaliers pranger 5 qui
en prend g5 fou prend g5 et maintenant
on veut jouer sur ce clou âge ladd et
dans certaines variantes si les noirs
jouent avec 5 on pourra avoir des 5 et
f4 pour utiliser cette tour en f1 et
maintenance camara ce qu'il y ait
des joueurs u15 jouables
quand il sait si ce jouet de la partie
tout à fait jouable moi chaque fois par
contre ça mène à l'égalité à la vérité
mais après on a beaucoup beaucoup de
coups trouvait donc maintenant bien sûr
eu cinq étaient prévus au poiré chaos
dans lequel est yakarouler de quatre
mois d'absence est beaucoup plus haut
c'est ce qu'il a joué dans la partie
c'est plus malins et freaky quoi il veut
jouer d'un mètre quatre est touché le
cavalier il a joué tout reprend des
quatre hikaru tour prend des quatre
cavaliers prend des quatre dames f4 ici
pour trouver l'égalité avec les noirs il
fallait jouer dan 17 puis cavaliers ces
deux échecs c'est assez compliqué on
montrera dans la vidéo plus longue il a
joué cavalier ces deux échecs direct qui
est plus logique un première vue roi des
huns d'amd cet échec roi français de
damas quatre échecs roi bentham prend le
cadre d'un point quatre cavaliers
prendre quatre attaques le fou fou f4 et
c'est ici la fin de la préparation
d'alireza firoud déjà qui a un avantage
dans cette position parce qu'il a le duo
tour fou contre tours cavaliers avec
le pion h passées qui pourrait être
soutenu par le fou donc c'est une finale
plus agréable non on va voir qui
carreaux va bien défendre en tout cas
les premiers coups tu vas jouer cavalier
c6 pour s'installer sur la case des 5
d'où il ne sera plus chassables h quatre
cavaliers des cinq touches le fou et le
fou qui repart en d2 flat pour
éventuellement peut-être pouvoir venir
en c3 un jour
exactement donc ici hikaru qui a très
bien vu une nouvelle fois il a joué f5
avec l'idée d'empêcher j'ai 4 h 5
l'avancé des pions g3 parce que sur f3
il y aurait f4 qui serait pénible pour
fixer la structure donc il a commencé
par g3 est maintenant wife 7 vlad le roi
qui a
se place pour laisser éventuellement la
case g8 à la tour est joué et a chuté
aussi f3 de la part d' ali reza en se
disant sûr tour g8 je vais faire j'ai
quatre et je vais jouer sur le vis-à-vis
tourache 8 10 cars ou bien jouer pour
surtout rachat se faire tour g8 et qui
est plus le vis-à-vis et alireza qui
joue fou g5 protège le pion et prépare
g4 est ici car ou qui a refait une
erreur il aurait dû probablement joué le
pour prendre le plat possession du
centre edf positionnelle très important
c'est que après eux cinq jeux 4 à part
de roanne sicilia f4 et conquois lofo
jeu sur jeu 5 un petit peu au port
bloqué ça aurait été mieux joué il a
joué ses cadres dans la partie ali reza
qui a joué g4 donc toujours pareil un
pion prends tu comprends mais en échec
bessin qui continue sa poussée à l'ale
dam tour d un menace si on prend f5 qui
ont pris cinq tours prend des cinq donc
force la prise puis on prend à eux cinq
maintenant alireza une excellente
position il a réussi à obtenir ses deux
pions passé lien il n'a pas joué cinq
pardon il a joué à cinq mais il a réussi
à obtenir ses deux pions passé lié à 5
de la part
d'alireza pour pousser les pions tour g8
attaque le fouet h6 très bien joué non
bref un échec
rue89 6 très durement au point par
seconde avec l'idée surtout reprend j'ai
5 h 7 et la tour ne pourrait plus
revenir défendre hikaru qui a joué touré
fuite ici et là l'iresa après pas mal de
calcul va jouer tourcoing f8 qui paraît
gagner à noter que tours h1 donné un
gros avantage est seul tour g8 mende et
l'égalité qui aurait sûrement pas trouvé
mais tout reprend en fuite les deux
hommes pensaient que c'était gagnant
pour les blancs à ce moment là de la
partie mais après fou des huit touches
le pion à 4 seul coup j'ai cinq rois et
vii pour bloquer h7 roi g7 et g6 il se
trouve qu'après ces trois vlad la
position est complètement
nul à cause d'une géométrie incroyable a
donc après puis on prend cavaliers prend
roi ces deux cavaliers des cinq les
blancs ne peuvent pas réussir à taper
sur la diagonale avec le fou on peut
montrer deux variantes sur fourrages 4e
5 fu g3 pour venir jouer fou prend eu
cinq échecs il ya cavaliers f4 et là on
va avoir un problème c'est qu'on menace
de récupérer les pions et surtout prend
comprends c'est carrément les noirs qui
vont être gagnant parce qu'ils ont deux
pions passé éloigné
est sûr qu'à valider cinq si on joue
disons roi des trois il ya cavaliers f4
échec et récupère et si on fait roi des
2,5 en fait on va jamais avoir accès à
rien d'intéressant si on va en ce 2 il
ya cavalière quatre échecs récupère en
e3 on peut pas y aller ni en d3 il ya
les chèques et si on passe en lin il va
y avoir des quatre et sur fion prend à 3
et contre je
aleida mais ici ça aurait carrément ait
de gagnant pour les noirs donc les deux
hommes contraints de faire nul
voila en fait le taux de klose ont
pourtant été dit leur solidité en fera
dans le résumé d'après-match
3,5 hommage pas froisser les bonnes
choses
ouais complexe
et les autres les oies le warm up
qu'on va mettre en grand en toute façon
il n'y a plus rien à dire sur les deux
parties à part regarder la came as les
fans du comtat c'est
imprévisible et man ça va être laide les
rendent très pacifique que tout va se
terminer par m
alors que ça envoyait de partout
alors qu'elles sont le pronostic il voit
à cordes bagnols d'un combien de temps
dix minutes 15 minutes en demeure
france 20 minutes et toi je pense ils
voient accorder nul doute
quelques minutes
est ce qu'il est ce qu'on va sortir le
résumé de la partie express
avant la fin de la partie
basse et ludwig là qui travaillent
après résumé détaillé mais ça sera
facile à faire je peux préparer en fait
d'ailleurs
tu peux me l'envoyer
on va même pouvoir se prendre permettre
une petite balade ce soir non
la journée n'a pas été trop fatigante et
en plus il faisait moins chaud
aujourd'hui en fait je suis en pleine
forme
presque envie de prendre un deuxième
shooter
c'est terrible hein c'est petit shoot
mieux de vie de travail travail dans le
sens travailler mais complètement cet
homme travaille
cet homme travaille même d'arrache-pied
pour que vous puissiez suivi le suivre
les live
vous ayez les rediffusions
mais trop si c'est la dernière devra
alors c'est la dernière sans être la
dernière parce qu'on va s'organiser on
va voir je sais pas quel moment tu
voudras passer du coup
à partir de round 4
je pense ça dépend de la coupe de cours
de partie 6e lire intéressant peut-être
euros plutôt que preview maintenant
vraiment je pense que je vais passer par
le cinquième site
4e 4e potter peut-être trois heures et
demie je sais pas où le monde ait notes
ou quatre heures pour donner ton point
de vue
vers 3h30 4h ouais
mais après tu dois être très content de
voir fab aussi
très contente de voir que le faire je
suis
tu vas aller à la plage
mais tu vas à la plage pour nager
je pensais pour draguer quoi
chose
que nager ou que de nous suivre
ma chère aux suiveurs et tréguier
c'est difficile de combiner les trois en
même temps
en fait c'est bizarre nager et nous
suivre c'est possible draguer et pas
dommage et c'est possible d'être dragué
suivre et partager en mettant vos stream
qua non ça je pense que c'est tellement
fou et monstres comme ça je pense ça
marche pas
après s'il faisait un peu plus frais et
aurait pu avoir le goût du blitz crime
ça saccharides ouf le woody qu'on peut
trouver sur la boutique important combat
je met un petit point d'exclamation
chapin
bah oui on va faire une petite pub pour
la boutique
a bien pu à doha où une petite pub comme
ça là on a vu l'essentiel de toute façon
aujourd'hui
pub qui fait quand même plaisir on a été
jusqu'à onze mille à suivre cette partie
aujourd'hui vlad
nettement plus qu'à voir beaucoup de
monde en plus on n'a pas une première
page twitch donc c'est quasiment autant
que ce qu'on avait en moyenne sur la
dernière phase des candidats d'ailleurs
bizarrement aujourd'hui
étonnamment
ce atari grand ou petit l'audi taille
normale en fait
dimanche après ouais mais les derniers
candidats on était en confinement donc
confinement est encore au mieux que
dimanche
c'était pas mal ce qu'on était en
général entre 14 et 17 milles sur les
autres candidats mais on était tous les
jours en première page de twitch donc ça
faisait un bout de trois quatre mille
personnes donc étonnamment on n'a eu
quasiment autant de gens que sur les
derniers candidats aujourd'hui partie
enfin les autres jours ce n'est pas le
cas mais aujourd'hui oui mais on n'est
pas en confinement donc on était
étonnamment beaucoup vlad
on n'avait plus qu'à 38 ouais mais on
avait eu un raid de sardasht javan et
10000 personnes
plus la première page twitch
ok là si on a
à un moment donné un raid de cas métaux
ou quoi on va peut-être 50 milous 60
milles mais je veux dire par là que
c'était 30000 antique avec
avec toutes ces choses là mais sinon on
était plutôt dans les 14 15 mille donc
aujourd'hui on était presque autant et
on est en confinement
j'ai retrouvé la dernière ronde du top
16 aujourd'hui ça doit jouer j'ai passé
très regardé
les faits mais elle joue beaucoup je
sais pas parce que par exemple
aujourd'hui on était plus que pour le
championnat du monde de blitz
globalement on a été juste à la fin fin
14 15 min pour le championnat du monde
deux buts mais sinon on était entre 5 et
8 milles donc je sais pas imprévisible
et pour toi
je pensais que ça ferait 8000 maximum
par exemple un an aujourd'hui est
vraiment beaucoup de monde c'est aussi
parce qu'ils car où il est connu
on avait fait me traoré n'ont en effet
trente mille max à un moment il y avait
le rêve de sa femme c'est
des gens tellement de mal des fois
mettre en relation la aujourd'hui avait
beaucoup de monde relativement à au fait
qu'ils aient pas eu de facteurs
extérieurs qui a amené du monde y avait
beaucoup de monde
mais ouais c'est l'effet hikaru très
clairement
cuire au pass depuis combien de temps et
de coûts
à 40 minutes déjà top 16 ses mille
personnes - top 16 j'ai pu passer avec
genre quatre sont 300 400 personnes
j'ai pas vu à 1000 personnes mais je
peux checker en fait
je sais comment de chaque les stats
j'ai la flemme de le faire
après j'ai pas regardé donc je veux pas
dire j'ai juste vu comme ça en passant
jade est ce que tu te considères plus
fort que sébastien mazet il peut y avoir
un piège dans la question
je les jouais je n'ai jamais joué avec
les noix je laisserai que avec les
poireaux et donc je sais pas qu'est-ce
que tout cas c'est tiré au poids moscou
14 euros
je suis ce qui se passe à chartres où je
suis ce qu'ils aient une femme plusieurs
fois et je regarde un peu ce que font
les gens que je connais mais globalement
non
d'ailleurs écoutez quand j'ai passé du
tout bref qu'ils gagnent top 16 qui a
gagné toutes ses unités
c'est qui daniel bélair clichy ou qui
n'ont cessé les rares et asnières seller
de gaza
aucune idée je suis pas du tout je suis
moi qui joue toujours pour bus scolaire
nous inquiète toujours voilà de quoi de
quoi les maximes joue pour asnières mais
je ne savais pas du tout qui avait gagné
en fait j'ai pas suivi en vrai
c'est la première fois je pense qu'ils
ont joué avec eux cester de poule haute
peut-être ya longtemps c'était déjà
mais ouais non j'ai pas du tout suivi
c'est fou de mètres de compétition aussi
importante en même temps à mais en fait
le top 16 c à 0 importance
comparativement les échecs c'est un
sport individuel et tout se joue sur le
truc du cycle mondial en fait
on va dire que la fidi considère pas le
top 16 comme importante du
tout c'est un comédien dans ses grimaces
de ferrou qu'est-ce que je les connais
tous
ces deux trois dernières minutes qu'une
pensée là il voit faire n'importe quel
coût 3 5 le plus ou mois et voit
regarder sur wigan
d'ailleurs il doit se dire que de toute
manière ces news vaut mieux quand même
peu se dépêcher pour
le top 16 c'est quoi en fait bas c'est
l'équivalent des interclubs au tennis en
fait on peut pas dire que c'est
l'équivalent de la ligue 1 parce qu'on
peut pas comparer un sport individuel un
sport collectif mais à
mais c'est l'équivalent des interclubs
en tennis
mode et moi qu'est ce que je connais le
mois d'août à mi année
4,5 avec 3,6 cavalli province en cas
d'accord
disent que toi tu avais joué dans ce
système là
avec cannes à l'époque n'en aura jamais
de gros
à chaque fois
non
on a toujours tout les autres jouer
toutes les autres équipes sous peu
non non non pas tous les autres équipes
n'ont quand même pas bon parcours à
wimbledon
existeront déjà oui j'aurais
des groupes différents
ou là j'ai presque oublié
non plus ne pas paraître de tennis où
les joueurs s'en vont les échecs les
interclubs les joueurs s'y intéresse non
mais faut pas expliqué que les
interclubs je dis pas donc pas fini ta
carrière j'ai gagné les interclubs à des
interclubs monde est d'accord qu aux
échecs ça compte pour rien les